MEETING TO ORDER WE'RE GONNA
BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
SERGEANTS IF YOU'D CONTACT THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF US SO THAT WE
COULD ESTABLISH.
QUORUM AT THE SOONEST AVAILABLE
OPPORTUNITY LOGAN HOUSEKEEPING
FOR EVERYONE'S AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER --
TWO HUESO HAS BEEN PULLED --
ITEM NUMBER THREE SEVEN NINE
FOUR STERN HAS BEEN PULLED.
AND WE'RE GOING TO A BEGINNER.
WITH MISTER DODD.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B. TEN
EIGHTY EIGHT WELCOMING A SENATOR.
S. B. TEN EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD
ESTABLISH REQUIREMENTS FOR
UTILITIES PROTECT AGAINST DAMAGE
FROM.
DIFFERENT NATURAL DISASTERS AND
WILD FIRES AS WELL AS INVEST IN
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES.
THAT WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
THE RISK OF IGNITING NEW
WILDFIRES.
NOT WITHSTANDING APPROVING COST
SAVINGS OF AT LEAST THREE TO ONE
THE CP YOU SEE IS NOT
ESTABLISHED ADEQUATE STANDARDS
FOR UTILITIES. TO REDUCE THE
RISK OF WILDFIRES CAUSED BY
UTILITY EQUIPMENT.
AND MAKE THEIR WEEK EQUIPMENT
MORE RESILIENT AND RESISTANT TO
DAMAGE FROM MAJOR DISASTER YOU
VETS.
SP TEN EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD
REQUIRE THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. TO ESTABLISH STANDARDS
FOR UTILITIES TO PROTECT AGAINST
DAMAGE FROM A VARIETY OF NATURAL
DISASTERS.
IT REQUIRE UTILITIES FILE SAFETY
RELIABILITY AND RESILIENCY
PLANTS WITH THE CPUC.
PLAN DEVELOPMENT WOULD BE
COORDINATED WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND FIRE AGENCIES.
THE PLANT WOULDN'T INCLUDE ALL
ESTIMATED COST TO IMPLEMENT THE
PLAN IN THE CPUC WOULD REVIEW
MODIFY APPROVED THE PLANS
INCLUDING THE COST TO IMPLEMENT
THEM.
ESTABLISHING A STATE STANDALONE
SAFETY PROCEEDING WOULD REQUIRE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES IN THE
CPU CD GIVE GREATER ATTENTION.
TAKE CARE TO SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY.
THE BILL WOULD ESTABLISH STRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY REQUIREMENTS IN
PROVIDE FOR PUBLIC INPUT FOR
PLAN DESIGN.
UTILITIES WOULD BE OR PROHIBITED
FROM DIVERTING MONEY TO SAFETY
RELIABILITY RESILIENCE AND
PROHIBITED FROM DELEGATING
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE PLAN TO ANY
[inaudible]
OTHERS.
MOREOVER S. B. TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
WOULD MAKE THE PLANNING AND RATE
PROCESS FOR SAFETY RELIABILITY
AND RESILIENCE.
TRANSPARENT AND PUBLIC.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE ANALYSIS
DESCRIBED SEVERAL AMENDMENTS I
AM OFFERING AS AUTHOR IT'S
AMENDMENTS AND THIS IS ON PAGE.
EIGHT OF YOUR ANALYSIS.
THESE AMENDMENTS MAKE CRYSTAL
CLEAR THAT NOTHING IN THIS BILL
SHOT OBLIGATE RATEPAYERS TO PAY
FOR UTILITY NEGLIGENCE.
REPAIR SHALL NOT BE OBLIGATED TO
PAY FOR ANYTHING NOT APPROVED
UNDER THE STATE HE PLAN.
IN THE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY.
THAT NOTHING IN THIS BILL WILL
REMOVE OR ADD ANY C. C. A.
AUTHORITY IN CURRENT LAW.
WITH THE BILL.
IN THESE AMENDMENTS GIVE
GUIDANCE TO THE CPUC WHEN
DETERMINING THE FAIR ALLOCATION
OF COSTS TO IMPLEMENT THE SAFETY
PLAN.
S. B. TEN EIGHTY EIGHT IS
SUPPORTED BY A BUSINESS LABOR
UTILITIES LOCAL GOVERNMENT MORE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THEY SAID WE'RE GOING --
TO PAUSE AND ESTABLISH A CORE.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
GREAT [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
ACOSTA [inaudible]
HERE AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BONTA.
DALY HERE GALLAGHER.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON [inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
GLORIA [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LIVING HERE BUT LOW.
RUBIO [inaudible]
SILAS [inaudible]
WALDRON.
WITH THE BILL.
OKAY WE HAVE A QUORUM ESTABLISH
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
I DO WE HAVE --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBER SCOTT
WHAT SHOULD BE AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS CAN BE VERY BRIEF MAKE
THREE POINTS.
BECAUSE OF THE LIABILITY ISSUES
IN THE WILD FIRES WITH MOST
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE IS THAT
EVERY YEAR.
THE UTILITIES GET ABOUT 25% OF
THE MONEY THEY INVEST INTO THE
SYSTEM FOR OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE FROM THE INVESTMENT
COMMUNITY.
THAT'S NOW GONE SO AT A TIME
WHEN WE NEED TO INVEST TO HARDEN
THE SYSTEM TO MAKE IT MORE
FIREPROOF.
WERE ACTUALLY GONNA HAVE LESS
THEN A ROLE YOU HAVE 75% OR LESS
OF THE DOLLARS WE TYPICALLY
WOULD HAVE TO INVEST.
SO THIS BILL IS CRITICAL IN THAT
IT FORCES THE P. YOU SEE FOR THE
FIRST TIME TO FOCUS ON SAFETY
AND AND PUT MORE TIME AND EFFORT
INTO SAFETY.
THE SECOND THING THAT THIS BILL
DOES IS IT OPENS UP THE PROCESS
TO ALLOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LOCAL
FIRE OFFICIALS TO PART TO PAY.
AND THEN LASTLY THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE AUTHOR WORKED OUT WITH
THE COMMITTEE ARE REALLY
GROUNDBREAKING MISTER CHAIRMAN.
IN TWO RESPECTS IT SAYS THAT.
NGUYEN THESE PLANS ARE ADOPTED
AND WIN THE PEACE YOU SEE THEN
ADOPTS.
A A RATE INCREASE LIKE THEY DO
IN EVERY RATE CASE. FOR
INVESTMENT BUT WHEN THEY ADOPT A
RATE INCREASE TO HELP PAY FOR
THIS INVESTMENT IN THE SYSTEM.
THAT THEY'VE THE RATE INCREASE
HAS TO BE PROPORTIONAL TO THE
BENEFIT.
THAT IS RECEIVED BY EACH RATE
TEAR.
EACH RATE CLASS SO THAT IT
PROTECTS AGAINST --
FOR INSTANCE THERE'S CONCERNS
THAT PERHAPS INDUSTRIAL OR
AGRICULTURAL OR BUSINESS --
RATEPAYERS WOULD BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIT THIS
PROTECTS AGAINST THAT THE SECOND
THING THAT IT DOES THAT IS
GROUNDBREAKING.
IS IT IS STATES THAT WHEN THE
RATE INCREASE IS APPROVED LIKE
IT IS IN EVERY GENERATE CASE TO
PAY FOR THESE INVESTMENTS.
THAT THE RATE INCREASE HAS TO BE
APPLIED [inaudible]
GEOGRAPHICALLY.
CONSISTENT WITH THE AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT IN EACH OF THOSE
AREAS FOR EXAMPLE [inaudible]
IF.
SEVERAL HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IS APPROVED IN.
NEED --
TERRITORY FOR CERTAIN
INVESTMENTS IN THE SYSTEM.
AND A A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF
THEM ARE BEING APPLIED IN THE
STATE. 80% OF ITS GOING TO THE
BAY AREA AIR 80% IS GOING TO ONE
PARTICULAR AREA.
THE RATE INCREASE WE
PROPORTIONATE TO WEAR THAT
BENEFIT WILL GO SAID THE RATE
PAYERS WILL ONLY BE PAYING FOR
THAT HARDENING OF THE SYSTEM.
IN THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY AND
THEN OVER YEAR OVER THE YEARS AS
THEY GO THROUGH IN AND HARDEN
THE SYSTEM IT WILL BE UP APPLIED
EQUITABLY SO UP FOR THOSE
REASONS WE WOULD.
URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MARK JOSEPH
WHEN HALF OF THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
I'VE BEEN A LAWYER PRACTICING
BEFORE THE P. YOU SEE FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS AND I'VE
INVOLVED AND GENERATE CASES FOR
ALL OF THAT TIME.
AND WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT
SAFETY RELIABILITY IS NOT THE
FOCUS OF THOSE RATE CASES.
AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT THIS
BILL THIS IS GOING TO SOLVE.
RIGHT NOW STE SAFETY RELIABILITY
IS JUST A BY PRODUCT OF HAGGLING
OVER MONEY AND THERE'S NEVER A
DIRECT FOCUS ON SAFETY
RELIABILITY.
THIS BILL.
WOULD IMPLEMENT A TWO STEP
PROCESS.
EVERY OTHER YEAR EACH UTILITY
HAS TO FILE A SAFETY RELIABILITY
PLAN.
IT WILL GET FULL REVIEW IT COULD
AT EXACTLY THE SAME LEVEL OF
DETAIL AS ANY RATE CASE GETS.
FULL REVIEW BY THE COMMISSION
AND BY ALL THE INTERESTED
PARTIES --
ANY LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ANYBODY
INTERESTED IN SAFE RELIABILITY
IN THEIR COMMUNITY CAN
PARTICIPATE.
AND SECOND THAT THE COMMISSION
AFTER APPROVING THOSE PLANS AND
THE COST TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
PLANS.
THEN EVERY YEAR AND THIS IS A
BRAND NEW THING WHICH DOESN'T
EXIST NOW EVERY YEAR THE
COMMISSION.
WE'LL EVALUATE WHETHER THE
UTILITY COMPLIED WITH ITS PLAN
AND THERE CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
AND IF THEY FAIL TO COMPLY WITH
THE PLANT THEY WILL BE FINE.
THIS IS SOMETHING WHICH DOES NOT
EXIST NOW AND SHOULD GREATLY
INCREASE THE SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY BECAUSE UTILITIES
FEET WILL BE HELD TO THE FIRE.
SPECIFICALLY ON THE ISSUE OF
COSTS.
THIS BILL IS BEEN AMENDED ABOUT
SIX TIMES NOW.
AND WITH EACH AMENDMENT THERE'S
BEEN MORE AND MORE FOCUSED TO BE
SURE THAT THIS DOES NOT GRANT
ANY KIND OF A BLANK CHECK TO THE
UTILITIES --
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THIS BILL NOW SAYS THAT ALL THE
COSTS THAT ARE APPROVED HAVE TO
BE JUST AND REASONABLE --
AND IN PARTICULAR IS MISTER WEST
SAID.
THE PAYING FOR ANY INCREASE
COSTS THAT ARE APPROVED WILL BE
FOCUSED BOTH GEOGRAPHICALLY AND
BY RATE CLASS FOR THE FIRST TIME.
SO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE GETTING
THE BENEFITS WILL BE PAYING A
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT GETTING THE
BENEFITS WON'T BE PAYING.
THIS IS A A CAREFULLY BALANCED
IN MEASURE PROVISION WHICH WILL
IMPROVE THE SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY OF THE SYSTEM.
HOPEFULLY DECREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF FUTURE FIRES AND
OTHER DISASTERS --
AND HELP US RECOVER FROM THEM
AFTERWARDS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN --
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS HERSH TURN
I'M WITH THE IBEW LOCAL TWELVE
FORTY FIVE WE REPRESENT THE
WORKERS AT MANY UTILITIES IN
NORTHERN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AND IN PARTICULAR P.
JEANNIE --
WE HAVE TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS WORKING AT PGE.
SO -- THE
WORD IS SAFETY --
YOU'VE HEARD IT PROBABLY.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TIMES ALREADY
I'M GONNA SAY IT AGAIN AND IF I
COULD SAY IT FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
TIMES.
AGAIN I WILL ACCEPT I'D PROLLY
BORE YOU --
A FOCUS OF THE ANALYSIS --
ALSO INCLUDES PACIFIC RIGHT --
REVISIONS AND IMPROVEMENTS TO
GEO NINETY FIVE THE GENERAL
ORDERS FOR US IN THE IBEW OUR
SAFETY BIBLE --
THIS IS HOW WE KEEP THE SYSTEM
SAFE THE IMPROVEMENTS HERE AND
THE FOCUS ON GENERAL ORDERS ARE
BECAUSE THEY ARE IN ADEQUATE. TO
DEAL WITH THE CURRENT CLIMATE
CONDITIONS WE NEED TO CHANGE
THEM AND WE NEED TO CHANGE AND
IMPROVE THE SYSTEM THE
DISTRIBUTION AND TRANSMISSION
SYSTEM.
IN ORDER TO ASSURE THAT THOSE
THAT THE CHANGES DO MEET THE
NEEDS THAT WE HAVE IN THE FIELD
OUR MEMBERS ARE MORE THAN HALF
EAGER TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
CUSTOMERS.
AND THE AND THE CALIFORNIA AS A
WHOLE ARE SAFE AND WE WERE IN WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE AS WE HAVE --
FOR SEVENTY FIVE YEARS NOW --
AND WE KNOW THAT WE CAN BUT WE
WANT THIS WE NEED THIS BILL TO
ENSURE THAT THAT FOCUS THE FOCUS
ON SAFETY IS WHAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING.
CONSISTENTLY AND FROM HERE ON
OUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
.
THERE ARE AN ABSOLUTE.
BILL HONOR JR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MATT BROWN
ON BEHALF OF ENGINEERS AND
SCIENTISTS OF CALIFORNIA YOU W.
YOU A LOCAL ONE THREE TWO ONE
SPORT THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHRIS PATTERSON ON
BEHALF OF PACIFIC GAS AND
ELECTRIC AND STRONG SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
OPAQUE HOUSE A PRESIDENCY INDIA
GAS ELECTRIC IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IT SEEMS AT A MINIMUM WE HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO DO THIS AND
STRENGTHEN THE SYSTEM.
KEEP EVERYBODY SAFE AND CHRIS
ARE ABILITY TO HAVE RESPONDED
THESE WILDFIRES THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS CARE ABOUT
WAS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
IN SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
THAT AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK RETURN CONSUMER.
ADVOCATES AS WELL AS ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
THEIR NUMBER PROBLEMS WITH THE
BILL BELOW ME JUST FOCUS ON ONE
AND THAT IS THAT THE MAJOR CRUX
OF WHAT THIS BILL IS DOING THAT
CONCERNS US.
IS THAT IT WILL.
ENABLE.
UTILITIES TO SHIFT COSTS OF
MAJOR EVENTS TO RATEPAYERS IN A
WAY THAT IS NOT ALLOWED UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
IT IS A MAJOR CHANGE.
LET ME LET ME JUST CLARIFY AND
IT IT IT ADDRESSES THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN TODAY.
THERE TO PROCESSES RIGHT NOW
THERE IS THE CIVIL ACTION IN
COURT LITIGATION THAT TAKES
PLACE OF P. GENIUSES.
PARALLEL TO THAT THERE IS AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS THAT IS
HANDLED THE CPUC.
IN COURT YOU LOOK AT NEGLIGENCE
THE COMMISSION YOU LOOK AT
WHETHER NOT UTILITY ACTED
PRUDENTLY [inaudible]
I IN THE MAJOR MEN WHETHER THEY
IT SHOULD BE LIABLE SHOULD PAY
FOR THE COSTS OF THE MAJOR EVENT.
IF UTILITIES FOUND. TO HAVE
ACTED IMPRUDENTLY IN THE
COMMISSION.
WILL NOT ALLOW RATEPAYERS TO
COVER THE COSTS OF A MAJOR EVENT.
WITH THIS BILL DOES IS REPLACE
THAT [inaudible]
FACT FINDING.
RIGHT NOW THE COMMISSION LOOK AT
ALL FACTS RELATED TO THIS
SPECIFIC EVENT.
AND DETERMINAR ABILITY.
THE BILL INSTEAD.
WOULD ONLY ALLOW THE COMMISSION
ASK ONE QUESTION.
AND THAT IS IS THERE A PLAN.
THAT HAS BEEN SUBSTANTIALLY
COMPLIED WITH THAT'S IT NOT ALL
FACTS.
ONLY IF THE PLANET BEEN
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLIED WITH AND
THAT IS A MAJOR PROBLEM.
BECAUSE THERE MAY BE FACTS THAT
WOULD INDICATE LIABILITY FOR THE
UTILITY.
WHICH PREVENT SHIFTING THE COSTS
TO RATEPAYERS.
BUT TEN NEED IT WOULD NOT ALLOW
THAT LET ME BE CLEAR THIS IS FOR
THE CPC PROCEEDING.
THE LANGUAGE TODAY THE INTENT
LANGUAGE WAS TAKEN TODAY.
REFERS TO NEGLIGENCE THAT IS A
COURT PROCEEDING.
THAT IS NOT TO SEE THE CPC
PROCEEDING.
AND IN THE EVENT THAT 99% THE
TIME THESE CASES ARE SETTLED IN
COURT OR OUT OF COURT WITHOUT A
TRIAL.
THERE'S NO FINDING OF NEGLIGENCE
IT'S AN OUT OF COURT SETTLEMENT.
SO IT LEAVES UNTOUCHED.
PROVISION OF THE BILL THAT SAYS.
THE COMMISSION CAN ONLY LOOK AT
WHETHER THERE WAS A PLAN.
WAS A COMPLIED WITH.
IF IS COMPLIED WITH THEN THERE
IS AUTOMATIC.
LIABILITY SHIELD FOR THE UTILITY
WHICH MEANS THE RATEPAYERS.
WHO PAY FOR THE SAFETY
MITIGATION ON THE FRONT END?
WILL ALSO BE ABLE BE FORCED TO
PAY FOR THE COSTS OF THE
WILDFIRES TO ANY OTHER MAJOR
EVENT.
THAT IS A MAJOR PROBLEM AND THE
REASONS WHY WE ARE.
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL I'M HAPPY
ANSWER QUESTIONS ON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
MICHAEL SAW CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURES AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND FOR SOMEONE OF
KNOWLEDGE --
THE EFFORT OF THE CHAIR TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT WE
HAVE EXPRESSED --
BOTH IN MEETINGS AND PREVIOUSLY
IN -- IN
COMMITTEE HEARINGS AND THE
AUTHOR OF FOR WORKING ON THAT AS
WELL HOWEVER --
THEY DAY THEY DON'T GO FAR
ENOUGH THE FIRST RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENT TALKS ABOUT
CONSIDERING --
YEAH THESE FACTORS.
CONSIDER IS VERY WEAK --
BECAUSE IT DOES NOT MEAN THAT
THE PEACE YOU HAVE TO DO
ANYTHING DIFFERENT.
THEM WHAT THEY HAVE DONE TODAY.
ARE THEY CAN CONTINUE WITH THEIR
THE PROCESS AS THEY HAVE WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT THAT PROCESS
WORKS OUT.
VERY WELL FOR REPAIRS --
CONCERT OR IN ADDITION TO THAT --
I THINK IS MISTER HERNANDEZ IS
ALREADY EXPLAINED THE REDEFINING
JUST AND REASONABLE --
AS THIS BILL DOES.
CREATES A BIT OF A LOOP WHERE
JUST AND REASONABLE FEES INTO
THE SECTION FOR FIFTY ONE IN THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE.
SMITH TALKS ABOUT THAT'S WHAT
UTILITIES CAN PUT INTO THE RATES
WELL IF IT'S JUST AND REASONABLE%
MAKE IT PUT IT INTO THEIR RATES --
BEEN LATER THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE HAVE BEEN OFFERED BY THE
COMMITTEE TALK ABOUT --
MAKING SURE THAT IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH SECTION FOUR FIFTY ONE SO
THE BILL KINDA POINTS BACK
AROUND THROUGH SECTION FOR FIFTY
ONE BACK TO ITSELF WITH THE
AMENDMENTS.
AND THAT IS A CONCERN BECAUSE IT
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE OF THE
SUBSTANTIVE ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
TALKED ABOUT.
THE LAST POINT I'D LIKE TO MAKE
IS.
WE ALL AGREE --
1100% THAT THAT SAFETY IS
CRITICAL SAFETY IS IMPORTANT.
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO PREVENT
ALL WILDFIRES BUT IT SHOULD BE
OUR GOAL TO DO AS MUCH AS WE CAN
TO PREVENT THOSE --
AND MITIGATE THE DAMAGE TO YOUR
COMMUNITIES HOW TO OUR
BUSINESSES --
AND TO THE STATE AS A WHOLE.
HOWEVER THIS BILL GOES FURTHER
PROVIDING LIABILITY PROTECTION
TO THE UTILITIES AND
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THOSE
THOSE ISSUES WE CANNOT SUPPORT
THIS BILL THE TIME.
MICHAEL VOCAL OR ON BEHALF OF
THE AG ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING.
MANY OF THE LARGEST SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
FARMING OPERATIONS FOOD
PROCESSORS AND WATER AGENCIES
WHO YOU SIGNIFICANT ENERGY.
LIKE MISTER JOSEPH I'VE BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN RAPE CASES
GENERATE CASES BEFORE THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION NOW 428-
YEARS.
I'M I'M GONNA VIGOROUSLY
DISAGREE WITH HIS
CHARACTERIZATION THAT RAPE CASES
ARE NOT ABOUT SAFETY.
YOU CAN GIVE YOU TWO VERY
CONCRETE EXAMPLES. ONE IS WHAT'S
GOING ON RIGHT NOW AND THE SO
CAL GAS GENERAL CASE.
AS IT RELATES TO ALMOST ENTIRELY
THE IMPACTS AND SAFETY MEASURES
THAT HAVE PUT IN PLACE.
SINCE ONLY SO CANYON THEY'RE
ASKING 440% RATE INCREASE OF
THEIR CUSTOMERS TO COVER THE
COSTS.
SAME THING HAPPENED IN PJ NAY
FOLLOWING SAN BRUNO AS YOU MIGHT
EXPECT.
SO FOR SOMEONE TO SUGGEST THAT
THESE CASES AREN'T ABOUT SAFETY
IS JUST FLAT OUT WRONG.
THEY'RE ENTIRELY ABOUT SAFETY
WHEN SAFETY IS THE PRIMARY ISSUE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
HERE IN THE NEXT GENERAL RATE
CASE WITH P. JEANNIE.
RATES ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO
CUSTOMERS AS RIPPER ALL I'M WELL
AWARE WE KNOW WE'RE GOING TO BE
PICKING UP SOME ADDITIONAL COSTS
BECAUSE WE NEED TO MAKE THE
SYSTEM SAFER.
IN RATE PAYERS ARE GONNA PICK UP
THOSE COSTS THIS BILL
UNFORTUNATELY SET UP A PROCESS
WHERE I DO BELIEVE IT IS A
ALMOST A BLANK CHECK FOR THE
UTILITIES.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY SKIN IN THIS
GAME WHY WOULDN'T YOU SPEND
EVERY DIME THAT THE COMMISSION
WILL LET YOU SPEND ON SAFETY.
BECAUSE IT WILL REDUCE POTENTIAL
YOUR LIABILITY EVEN IF SOME OF
THOSE INVESTMENTS ARE NOT VERY
COST EFFECTIVE.
IT'S NOT YOUR MONEY YOU DON'T
CARE YOU'RE GONNA SPEND EVERY
DIME HUMANLY POSSIBLE BECAUSE
IT'S GREAT PAYER FUNDS.
AND THAT'S STILL A HUGE ISSUE WE
HAVE GOING FORWARD SO WE ALSO
HAD A LOVELY CHAT WITH THE HELL
OFFER LAST EVENING ABOUT THE
BILL -- WE
WERE FOR CLOSER TOGETHER WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT HE'S
DOING TO TRY AND MOVE IN THIS
DIRECTION.
IT NEEDS TO MOVE A LOT FURTHER
AYE THESE AREN'T THE ONLY ISSUES
WE'RE GOING TO BE TALKING ABOUT
YOU KNOW WHO PAYS FOR THE
EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
LIABILITY THAT'S LIKELY TO COME
OUT OF THE FIRES FROM LAST YEAR.
AND SOME OF THAT AND
UNFORTUNATELY IS PROBABLY ALSO
GOING TO BE SHARED.
BY CUSTOMERS AND OUR RATES ARE
READY EXORBITANT THROUGH THE
ROOF AND MUCH HIGHER THAN ANY
CUSTOMERS FACE IN ANY OTHER
STATE AND IN OUR SECTORS.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DON
GOBERT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY CHOICES SATIATION THE
CCA'S.
HOW WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR STAFF IN
WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR
STAFF?
HOW FOR ALL ó WHILE TO TRY TO
ADDRESS OUR TWO CONCERNS AND I
AGREE WITH THE --
SENATOR DODD CHARACTERIZATION OF
THE CCA AMENDMENT HERE WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT IT IT IT
MAINTAINS OBLIGATIONS AND
AUTHORITIES.
AND SO THAT GETS US 50% OF THE
WAY THERE AND AGAIN VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT THE OTHER 50% IS
RATE PAYER PROTECTION.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT UNDER
THE BILL AS WE TALK TO THE
AUTHOR AND THE STAFF IN
PARTICULAR FOR WEEKS.
ABOUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE BILL THAT THE RESOURCES
PROCURED UNDER THE BILL --
WOULD NOT BE PROCURED BY.
WE HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DO BUT
ALSO -- BY
IT I'LL USE OF FOR I SAID FOR
OUR CLIENTS FOR OUR RATE PAYERS.
ALSO IOUS FOR INADVERTENTLY
PERHAPS FOR OUR RATE PAYERS SO
THAT THEY WOULD BE DOUBLE BILLED
ALL WE WANT IS SOME LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD CLARIFY THAT THAT'S
NOT GONNA HAPPEN.
AND ACTUALLY --
WE WE DID DRAFT SOMETHING REAL
QUICK IN RESPONSE TO WHAT WE SAW
IN THE ANALYSIS TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
JERRY MEMBERS WE SUCH AS WHAT
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
WE LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH -- THE
ONES MADE BY SEEM TO THINK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOW AND HE'D GET ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN TO STASIO GROWERS --
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION WESTERN ON
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS IN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION.
I'M AND OTHER VARIOUS AG
INTERESTS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AS WAS STATED AGRICULTURAL
RATES ARE INCREDIBLY HIGH
AMNESTY --
AND THAT IS ADDED ON TO THE
AMOUNT OF WATER THAT WE HAVE TO
PUMP THE AMOUNT OF WATER THAT WE
HAVE TO MOVE THROUGH THIS STATE.
THOSE RATES ARE CONTINUING TO
INCREASE AND WILL INCREASE
DRAMATICALLY UNDER THE SPELL.
ALSO WITH OUR PROCESSORS ARE
PROCESSORS CAN MOVE OUT OF THE
STATE IF THEY HAVE TO THEY DON'T
WANT.
TO DEBATE WE ARE FORCING OUR
AGRICULTURAL PROCESSORS TO PICK
UP AND MOVE.
IF THAT HAPPENS OUR FARMERS THAT
ARE LEFT HAVING TO SHIP THEIR
GOODS FARTHER --
REQUIRING MORE ENERGY PRODUCTS
OR JUST SIMPLY GO OUT OF
BUSINESS SO YOU'D URGE YOUR NO
VOTE.
THANKS VERY MATH OF FRONTIER.
ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THAT'S A LOSS ON BEHALF OF
FOSTER FARMS IN THE CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA POULTRY FEDERATION IN
OPPOSITION. THIRTY YEARS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE FOOD PRODUCERS
ARE REPRESENTING THE FOOD
PROCESSING INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA JUST LIKE TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES.
ARE INDUSTRY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IS A VERY VERY --
DEPENDENT OBVIOUSLY ON ENERGY
UMBER VIA IS ONE OF OUR HIGHEST
COST OF DOING BUSINESS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE ONE
OF THE LARGEST JOB CREATORS IN
THE STATE.
OF OUR INDUSTRY IS THE SUFFERING --
FROM FROM HIGH COSTS IN A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT REALMS AND THIS
BILL IS ONLY GOING TO ADD TO
THAT PROBLEM THINK YOU.
KAREN MILLS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL ON ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH CMT A TURN IN THE
AGRA PRESENT IDEAS.
FARM BUREAU WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THE REFERENCE TO THE
VALUE OF HYDRO ELECTRICITY IS A
RENEWABLE RESOURCE THANK YOU.
OTHER HARTMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
ALSO OPPOSED TO THE BILL --
WE LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS --
WITH WHAT YOU'VE HEARD ALREADY
FROM C. MTA AND OTHERS THE
REPAIR GROUPS UPPER CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE
LANGUAGES IN THE BILL WOULD LIKE
TO WORK WITH YOU TO ADDRESS THAT.
CATHERINE BRANDENBURG
REPRESENTING CINEMA CLEAN POWER
WE ARE YOU SEE CA AND WE ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH MISTER GILBERT.
IN THAT WERE HALF WAY THERE.
WE HAVE A THANK YOU.
OKAY TO ANY ADDITIONAL.
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION.
SEEING THEM WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERSHIP FOR QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
OKAY --
AGAINST SUCH MY TURN.
AS YOU KNOW OF SENATOR DODD
LANCASTER CCA IS IN MY DISTRICT.
AND I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY I
HEARD SOME REFERENCES LEGAL BE
ACCEPTING LANGUAGE BUT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT --
THE PART OF THE THE BILL THAT
INDICATED THAT OF SIMPLE
INABILITY TO BEING DOUBLE BILLED
HAS BEEN RESOLVED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT OBVIOUSLY --
DO THE TEST HEARING THE
TESTIMONY THAT HAS NOT BEEN
FULLY RESOLVED WHERE HALF THE
WAY THERE.
I'M BUT I'VE GOTTA CENTER BEYOND
ALAN'S OFFICE RIGHT NEXT TO ME
WAS A FIERCE.
ADVOCATE FOR THIS AND WE'RE
WORKING WITH HIM AND HIS STAFF --
THE YOU KNOW TO TRY TO FIND
LANGUAGE THAT THAT WILL WORK
SOME OF THE LANGUAGE.
THAT HAS BEEN PRESENTED SO FAR
TAKES IT TOO FAR IT SO WE IT
IT'S A WORK IN PROGRESS MY
COMMITMENT IS.
TO YOU KNOW TO WORK WITH THEM
AND ALSO TO WORK WITH THE
ASSEMBLY OF THE WORKING GROUP ON
THIS ISSUE --
INCLUDE THAT IN THE THAT CCA.
YET ISSUE IN THAT AS WELL
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD --
SO I IT YOU JUST STATED THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO START IN THE
WORKING --
WITH -- SOME
MY COLLEAGUES REGARDING --
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COME SO IS
ENERGY COMMITTEE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT --
I HOPE IT KEEPS MOVING FORWARD
I'M ANXIOUS TO HELP THE HELP YOU
ANY WAY I CAN TO GET A GOOD
SOLID BIPARTISAN.
AGREEMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
I'VE --
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH --
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS --
AUTUMN BURKE AND HEATH FLORA WHO
ARE.
SEE SEEM TO BE THE POINT PEOPLE
FOR THE ASSEMBLY WORKING GROUP
HAVE COMMITTED TO THEM.
A TO DO JUST THAT.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO WHO ARE MISS
RUBIO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
I KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF WORK --
PUT INTO THIS AND I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR AND STAFF --
FOR FOR MAKING SURE THAT BIT
THIS KEEPS MOVING FORWARD JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT -- WE
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THE COR
CONCERNS ARE HIGHLIGHTED TODAY
WHICH IS THE EXTREME FINANCIAL
EXPOSURE TO MY CONSTITUENTS THAT
ARE AS RATE PAYERS.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
WORKING GROUP I KNOW THAT IT'S A
WORK IN PROGRESS BUT I'M REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT MY MY
CONSTITUENTS AND IF WE CAN --
ASSURE THAT THERE IS A
BIPARTISAN GROUP AND A REAL --
COMMITMENT TO MAKING THIS WORK I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT BUT
AGAIN WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT THAT.
WE ARE IT'S A WORK IN PROGRESS
LIBYA UNDERSCORE HOW IMPORTANT
THAT IS TO ME I HAVE MORE THAN A
THOUSAND WINERIES IN MY DISTRICT.
PLUS I COUNTLESS ACRES --
VINEYARDS ARE ALL IMPACTED THIS
ANHEUSER BUSCH AND MANY MANY
OTHER FACTORIES A BUSINESSES IS
EQUALLY IMPORTANT TO ME THAT WE
GET THIS RIGHT AS WELL SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT [inaudible]
IT'S GALLAGHER.
SOONER DOT AYE I WANTED TO POINT
OUT AGAIN THAT YOU KNOW THE BILL
IS AND UTILITIES --
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR TAKING
THIS ISSUE ON YOU KNOW AND AS AS
PEOPLE --
REPRESENTATIVES FROM DISTRICTS
THAT BOTH HAD FIRES RAVAGE
THROUGH --
ARE DISTRICTS AND BURNED DOWN
HOMES AND HAD AND WE'VE HAD
LIVES LOST --
THE STATUS QUO.
IS UNACCEPTABLE AND YOU KNOW SO.
BUT ONE OF THINGS I DID WANT TO
POINT OUT HERE IS THAT YOU KNOW.
THE CURRENT PROCESS HE'S
OBVIOUSLY AREN'T TAKING CARE OF
THEM THEY MAY ADDRESS SAFETY --
BUT THEY NO I DON'T THINK WE CAN
BE SATISFIED THE CURRENT PROCESS
IS GOING TO TAKE CARE OF THESE
ISSUES AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY
AT THE HEART OF YOUR BILL IS
THAT WE NEED TO SET --
THE BAR HIGHER --
FOR THE UTILITIES THAT THERE'S
MORE THAN YOU DO THEY NEED
APPROVED MINUTES --
AND THERE'S GOING TO BE A COST
THAT THERE'S A COST ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT.
AND AND YOU KNOW --
AND THE OTHER PART OF IT WHEN I
HEAR SAN HOME AND THE COSTS ARE
SO HIGH WILL.
THEY'RE NOT HIGH BECAUSE OF THIS
YOU KNOW ME YES THIS IS AN
ADDITIONAL COST BUT THE REAL
REASON THEIR HIGHS BECAUSE OUR
PS.
AND BECAUSE OF AB THIRTY TWO IN
THE THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE ALONG
THOSE LINES THAT'S WHY RATES ARE
SO HIGH AND THAT'S WHY IT'S BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT.
OF FOR FOR MANY DIFFERENT
BUSINESSES DEALING WITH THIS
ISSUE -- BUT
THE COST OF MAKING SURE THAT OUR
SYSTEM IS SAFE AND THAT ARE.
OUR HOMES OUR FAMILIES ARE SAFE
IS SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD ALL
BETTER NOW.
WE'VE TALKED A LITTLE BIT MY
CONCERN IS WITH THIS RECENT
AMENDMENT IT SEEMS THE MAYBE
SHIFT THE COST BURDEN --
TO ME I GUESS AND THE CASE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS FROM. ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS ONCE SAID A
CONSTITUENTS MY BENEFIT OTHERS
WOULD HAVE MORE THE COST SHIFTED
TO THEM.
NOW THIS IS ALL ONE BIG GRID
THAT WE ALL BENEFIT FROM.
YOU KNOW AND SO FOR ME.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT WE SHOULD
ALL BE.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE IN THE COSTS
EQUALLY OF WHAT.
WHAT IT TAKES TO MAKE THINGS
SAFER -- AND
YOU KNOW IN THE AND THERE ARE
OTHER ISSUES THAT I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT ABOUT HOW DO WE DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THE UTILITY CAN
PASS ACOSTA AFTER REPAIRS BUT WE
YEAH I KNOW WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
WORK ON THOSE ISSUES BUT WITH
THIS RECENT MEMBER THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT DOES.
GIVE ME CONCERNED I'D RATHER SEE
MORE OF AN EQUAL.
YOU LOOK WE ALL BENEFIT FROM
HAVING THIS GRID AND AND MAYBE
SHIP DONE ONLY A CERTAIN GROUP
OF OF RATEPAYERS OVER OTHERS.
DOES GIVE ME SOME PAUSE AND BUT
YOU KNOW I WANT TO CONTINUE. TO
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THAT ISSUE --
I GUESS AT THAT AMENDMENT IS
TAKE MY LAYOFF TODAY AND BUT I'D
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
YOU ON ON LANGUAGE.
OBVIOUS IT'S SUPPORTED IT AND
UTILITIES AND WANT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH YOU ON THIS ISSUE.
I'LL TAKE YOUR WORD MIGHT --
VERY SERIOUSLY [inaudible]
MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
AS WE ALL ALL THE UTILITIES ARE
CURRENTLY TAKING A BEARING A BIG
BURDEN AFTER THE FACT IF TO
FIRES HIT BOMB.
THE SAFETY AND RELIABILITY PART
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT --
CRITICAL FOR AREAS LIKE MINE
THAT YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE SOUTH
OF THE GRAPEVINE AND IT'S YOU
KNOW COASTAL SAGE AND JUST DRY
BRUSH BASICALLY ESERT AREA HOME.
WHEN THE SANTA ANA WINDS BLOW
EVERYONE GETS SCARED I MEAN WE
HAD THE CEDAR FIRE?
AND THE WHICH FIRE WITH THIRTY
SIX HUNDRED HOMES BURNED.
THE DEVASTATING IT TOOK OVER A
DECADE FROM PEOPLE WON'T GET
THEIR LIVES TOGETHER.
ON YOU KNOW I HAVE A SMALL
BUSINESS MY BUSINESS IS IMPACTED.
WHEN I LOOK BACK IT'S LIKE WE'VE
HAD [inaudible]
PROBABLY.
I OF FOUR FIVE MAJOR EVENTS OF
THE LAST FOURTEEN YEARS IN MY
AREA NOT COUNTING THE SMALL ONES --
WE JUST HAD THE LILAC FIRE THAT
IMPACTS MY BUSINESS YOU KNOW
WHEN THERE'S ASH ON THE GROUND
IN SCHOOLS A CLOSING EVERYTHING
THOUGH THOSE OF BIG ECONOMIC
HITS [inaudible]
SO.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE CONTINUE
TO TALK ABOUT THIS I MEAN
GATHERS ISSUES I THINK WE NEED
TO KEEP THE DISCUSSION GOING
[inaudible]
OBVIOUSLY [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
HAVING THE RATE PAYER PROTECTION
AS USUAL IMPORTANT BUT I'LL BE
LOOKING FOR YOU KNOW HASN'T
MOVES FORWARD.
ADOPTION OF STANDARDS FOR
REDUCING THE RISK OF A MAJOR
EVENT I LOOKAT YOU KNOW THE ST
LOUIS RAY TRAINING CENTER
THOROUGHBRED RACETRACK IN MY
DISTRICT. FIFTY TWO THOROUGHBRED
RACEHORSES DIED IN THE LILAC
FIRE BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T GET
OUT AND IT WAS ALL DUE TO FAN
POMS.
THAT ARE NEAR NON THEY'VE NON
NATIVE THERE ARE.
BASICALLY BLOWING OFF IN THE
WIND LIKE TORCHES THOSE THINGS
NEED TO BE WE GOTTA GET AHEAD OF
THESE MAJOR EVENTS --
PREVENTING MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
HITS ON THE SYSTEM GOING FORWARD.
ON MIDDLE LONG RUN WE'RE GOING
TO SAVE MONEY IS MY HOPE --
FOR HIGH A FIRE RISK AREAS WE
NEED TO KEEP THE DISCUSSION
MOVING.
ARM WE CAN AFFORD TO PUT IT
ASIDE WAY FOR THE NEXT FIRE
SEASON THE COM.
I THINK YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL FOR A STATE FOR THE
RATE PAYERS FOR A BUSINESS.
THAT WE GET THIS ISSUE SOLVED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE THE MOST LEVINE THE
MISTER GORE.
I CAN ASSURE MISTER I THINK --
FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL I KNOW
THAT YOU'VE GOT THE VERY BEST
INTENTIONS FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT SUFFERED --
AND ALSO LOOKING FORWARD FOR ALL
OF CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT ALL OF THE EFFORT THAT YOU
HAVE HERE.
I DO HAVE CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN EXPRESSED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL NEGATIVE IMPACT --
THAT THIS COULD HAVE ON UTILITY
RATE PAYERS AND OF PARTICULAR
CONCERN --
THAT WAS NOTED IN UTILITIES AND
ENERGY COMMITTEE BILL ANALYSIS
OUT WHERE THEY MADE THE POINT
THAT THIS BILL WOULD SUPPLANT
THE CPU SEES CURRENT REVIEW. TO
DETERMINE WHETHER UTILITY ACTED
REASONABLY OR IS A PRUDENT
MANAGER AFTER A FIRE HAS
OCCURRED.
INSTEAD THE CPC WOULD BASIS
DECISION ON WHETHER UTILITY WAS
IN SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE.
WITH ITS FILED AN APPROVED
SAFETY RELIABILITY AND
RESILIENCY PLAN.
AS ESTABLISHED BY THIS BILL THAT --
THAT YOU'VE AUTHORED AND THE
CONCERN IS THAT THIS COULD
SUBJECT RATEPAYERS TO EXTENSIVE
LIABILITY COSTS [inaudible]
MOREOVER ON NUMEROUS CPC
DETERMINATIONS WOULD BE MADE ON
AN EXPEDITED BASIS WITH LIMITED
EVIDENCE [inaudible]
UNLIKE.
A GENERAL RATE CASE PROCEEDED TO
COMMENT ON THAT PLEASE.
I'M A SECURE JOB MY WITNESS THAT
RESPOND TO THAT CERTAINLY.
THANK YOU MISTER LANE --
THE ANALYSIS THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO OVERLOOKED --
ONE SENTENCE THAT'S IN THE BILL
ALREADY WITH RESPECT TO AFTER
THE FACT FACTUAL ANALYSIS.
WHICH THE ANALYSIS SUGGESTED
WOULDN'T HAPPEN --
IN FACT IN --
SECTION TWENTY EIGHT NINETY NINE
POINT FOUR WHICH IS ON PAGE
FOURTEEN OF THE BILL.
IN LINE'S FOUR THROUGH SIX SAYS
THE COMMISSION SHALL CONDUCT AN
ANNUAL PROCEEDING. TO REVIEW
EACH UTILITIES COMPLIANCE WITH
ITS PLAN INCLUDING.
A FACTUAL ANALYSIS OF ANY MAJOR
EVENTS THAT OCCURRED
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
IT'S IT WILL STILL BE THE CASE
AT THE COMMISSION WILL DO IT
AFTER THE FACT REVIEW IF
SOMETHING HAPPENED TO DETERMINE.
WHETHER THE AGILITY COMPLY WITH
THIS PLAN ON ONE HAND OR WAS
NEGLIGENT ON THE OTHER.
SO THAT'S NOT BEING TAKEN OUT OF
OF THE PROCESS THAT'S
SPECIFICALLY CALLED OUT AS
SOMETHING THAT WILL OCCUR --
AND THE SECOND QUESTION YOU
ASKED WAS ABOUT.
BUT I'M I I WANT TO BE.
REALLY FOCUSED ON THE CHANGE IN.
OUR WHAT COMPLIANCE MEANS WHO
WHAT THAT'S HIM THAT IMPACT
MIGHT END UP BEING FOR
RATEPAYERS I THINK THAT'S WHAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE.
PRETTY PRETTY BROAD CONCERNS
ABOUT.
YES AND AND THAT'S WE WE'VE
HEARD THOSE CONCERNS AND THERE'S
BEEN A NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS TO
TRY TO ADDRESS IT.
THE LAST SET OF AMENDMENTS WHICH
ARE AUTHORS AMENDMENTS BEING
OFFERED IN THIS COMMITTEE --
WHICH ARE AT THE VERY END OF THE
BILL [inaudible]
SPECIFICALLY DISCLAIM ANY INTENT
[inaudible] TO CHANGE.
THE EXISTING UTILITY LIABILITY
FOR NEGLIGENCE IF THEY ARE
NEGLIGENT THEN THIS BILL DOES
NOT PROTECT THEM MOREOVER
SENATOR HILL --
WHO IS PATIENTLY WAITING TO
PRESENT ONE OF HIS BILLS NOT
THIS ONE SENATOR HILL HAS A BILL
WHICH ALSO EXPLICITLY PROHIBITS?
ANY RECOVER AND RECOVERY. FOR
NEGLIGENCE AND SENATOR DODD IS A
COAUTHOR THAT BILL [inaudible]
SO.
WHY UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY THE RATE PER GROUPS
WE'VE?
TAKE A LOT OF AMENDMENTS TO TRY
TO BE SURE THEIR FEARS ARE NOT
REALIZED ANSWER DOES THAT --
ALSO RELATED EXPEDITED BASIS AND
A LIMITATION ON EVIDENCE.
THERE IS NO LIMITATION THAT
EVIDENCE THE RATE CASE PLAN.
PROCEEDING --
WE'VE TAKEN A MEMBERS TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS THE FACT
THAT THAT PROCEEDING WILL BE A
FULL BLOWN PROCEEDING --
IT CAN TAKE AS LONG AS THE
COMMISSION NEEDS TO TAKE WE
THERE WERE CONCERNS ABOUT IT
BEING EXPLAINED TO COMPRESSED.
WE TOOK AMENDMENTS TO SAY WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE IT BE DONE IN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS BUT THEY CAN'T
FINISH IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS TAKE
AS LONG AS YOU NEED TO STEP BIG
MAKE A FINDING THAT ANY LONGER.
THAT'S EXACTLY THE SAME
REQUIREMENT THAT EXISTS AT ANY
RATE CASE RIGHT NOW.
I WILL THINK YOU I SEE THAT ONE
OF THE OTHER WITNESSES THAT
PROVIDED TESTIMONY HAS A COMMENT
ON THE IF I IF THE CHAIR DOESN'T
MIND.
I'M FROM MINISTER.
GOOD THANK YOU --
GONNA NOT YOUR HANDS BEHALF OF
TERMS -- ON
YOUR QUESTION REGARDING --
THE CURRENT PROCESS PROCESS AND
HOW THE BILL IS CHANGING IT.
THE THE PROPONENT A WITNESS JUST
STATED ABOUT THE NEGLIGENCE.
PIECE THAT IS IN THE AMENDMENTS.
THE USE OF THE WORD NEGLIGENCE
MEANS THAT THAT PROVISION THAT
LINE ONLY APPLIES TO THE COURT
PROCEEDING IT DOES NOT TOUCH.
THE CPUC PROCEEDING SO LET ME
JUST BE CLEAR IT SAYS WHERE
WHERE.
UTILITIES FOUND NEGLIGENT AND IT
CAN BE PASSED ON THAT NEGLIGENCE
FINALLY CAN FIND CAN ONLY OCCUR
IN COURT AND MOST OF THESE CASES.
MOST THE LITIGATION THERE
SETTLED OUT OF COURT THERE IS NO
FINDING OF NEGLIGENCE OR OR NON
A BUDGETS.
THE THE KEY THING ON YES THIS
BILL DOES REQUIRE A REVIEW OF A
MAJOR OF IT THAT IS TRUE
[inaudible]
DIFFERENCE IS THAT THE
COMMISSION.
DETERMINATION WOULD NO LONGER BE
ABOUT ALL OF THE FACTS RELATED
TO THE MAJOR EVENT IT WOULD ONLY
BE ON THE QUESTION WAS THE PLAN
SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLIED WITH THAT
IS THE MAJOR DIFFERENCE IN A
FIVE VERY BRIEFLY CAN JUST GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE THAT SOMEONE
REYES TO ME I'VE BEEN.
USING.
THE PLAN REQUIRES THAT A MILLION
TREES ARE CUT BACK.
FURTHER IF FURTHER CLEARANCE
FROM POWERLINES.
AND UTILITY CUT BACK.
ALL BUT THREE WOULDN'T THAT.
THAT WOULD BE SUBSTANTIAL
COMPLIANCE SOMEBODY WOULD ARGUE
AND SAY THEY SHOULD NOT BE
LIABLE.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHEN THEY ARE
GOING TO HURT.
THE DIFFERENCE WITH THIS BILL IS
THAT HER CURRENT LAW.
THAT MAY BE TRUE HOWEVER IF YOU
LOOK AT ALL THE FACTS WHAT IF.
THE UTILITY WAS RECEIVING CALLS
FOR CONSUMERS FOR TWO WEEKS
STRAIGHT.
THAT THOSE THREE TREES THAT THEY
HADN'T CUT BACK.
WERE SPARKING FIRES.
AND THEY DID NOTHING ABOUT IT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THAT FACT
WOULD BE CONSIDERED BY THE CPUC.
UNDER THIS BILL THAT FACT WOULD
NOT BE CONSIDERED IT WOULD ONLY
BE CONSIDERING WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE
AND ONE WOULD ARGUE THAT. THREE
TREES OUT OF A MILLION MIGHT BE
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLIANCE.
BUT IT CERTAINLY WOULDN'T TAKE
THEM AWAY FROM BEING IMPRUDENT
BY NOT RESPONDING TO TWO WEEKS
OF CALLS ARE CONSUMERS ABOUT THE
THREE TREES AND THAT'S A MAJOR
DIFFERENCE.
ARE YOU LOOK AT ALL THE FACTS
AND MAKE A DETERMINATION OF
LIABILITY.
IS CURRENT PROCESS ARE YOU GONNA
LOOK AT STATURE COMPLIANCE WITH
THE PLAN AND THAT'S IT.
NOT AT THIS BILL DOES AND
HOPEFULLY THAT HELPS.
I THINK YOU ARE AND WHAT THE
COMMITTEE DOES.
TO IS THE WRONG TERM THESE BUT
TO SUFFER.
GOING THROUGH THIS VERY GOING
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN THE TWO
DIFFERENT SIDES OF THIS IS.
I TO USE THE SAME TERMED A
SUBSTANTIAL ISSUE --
IN PRE MEDIA FOR FOR THAT ISSUE
THAT WERE WERE TRYING TO DEAL%
WITH.
OUT MR DOT IS THERE I'M NOT
ASKING YOU TO MAKE A CHANGE ARE
TAKEN AMENDMENT BUT I MEAN HOW
HOW DO YOU THINK YOU COULD --
TRY TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE OR IS
THIS DEFINITION IN THIS THIS
PART OF YOUR BILL SOMETHING THAT
IS MISINTERPRETED OR IT'S NOT
MISINTERPRETED IT YOU JUST CAN'T
CHANGE WITH WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH THIS ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISHING A LOT.
WITH A LOT OF THE OTHER STUFF IN
YOUR BILL THAT'S VERY GOOD --
BUT THIS MIGHT BE A BIT TOO MUCH.
I I I I I HEAR BOTH SIDES HERE
AND I'LL TELL YOU.
IF WHAT IT TAKES IS TO FIND
ANOTHER WORD BESIDES NEGLIGENCE
I DON'T NECESSARILY AGREE WITH
THE WITNESS --
FOR YA FROM TURN BAD --
RESPECT HIM AND AND EXPERIENCE
THAT HE HAS.
SO THAT MAYBE SOMETHING THAT WE
THAT'S NOT MAYBE SUBWAY NEED TO
LOOK AT WE WILL LOOK AT THAT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
WILL LOOK AT THAT WITH THE
WORKING THE ASSEMBLY WORKING
GROUP.
I THINK THAT'S YET THAT'S VERY
FAIR I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO
HAVE AN HONEST ARBITER --
THAT'S SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THE TWO
TWO ADDRESSED.
THE THE ISSUE THAT'S BEFORE US
BEFORE WE BRING IT --
TO APPROPRIATIONS PERHAPS OR
MOST CERTAINLY THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR AYE SO YOU HAVE A LOT OF
BILL HERE EVEN IF YOU.
DO NOT INCLUDE THIS SECTION OF
THE BILL.
BUT THAT DOES A LOT OF GOOD I
JUST WANNA MAKE THAT POINT.
ON I ALSO TRUST THAT YOU'LL WORK
OUT THE CCA ISSUE I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT'S TOTALLY DOABLE
I KNOW THAT YOU'VE YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO IT --
YOU KNOW I I AM JUST REALLY TORN
ON THIS BUT I WILL EXTEND THE
COURTESY VOTE TO YOU.
I DON'T KNOW HOW I WILL VOTE ON
IT ON THE FLOOR.
I HOPE THAT YOU RESOLVE THIS
ISSUE OR DELETE THAT PROVISION
THAT CAUSES A LOT OF
CONSTERNATION ABOUT A FIFTEEN OF
THE COST. TO RATEPAYERS AND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
EVERYONE WHO WE REPRESENT SHOULD
BE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
THANK YOU THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WHICH GLORIA.
THINKING IS CHAIRMAN JUST VERY
QUICKLY SAID ABOUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL AND FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO MAKE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS INCLUDING COMMENTS
HE JUST MADE.
A ABOUT A QUICK APPORTIONMENT OF
A OF LIABILITY I JUST WANT TO
SHARE I APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE TO IT BASICALLY
BEHALF ALL OF THAT CCA'S ARE
LOOKING AT I NEED YOU TO HEAR
FROM ME THAT MY COMMUNITIES MOST
OF THE CITIES IN MY DISTRICT ARE
WORKING. TO ESTABLISH CCA'S AS
WE SPEAK AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME THAT THAT PROCESS IS
SUCCESSFUL IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
CAN BE GIVEN CHOICE WHETHER TO
STAY WITH THE LEGACY UTILITY OR
MOVE ON I KNOW THAT THIS COULD
POTENTIALLY OR WHAT I'M TOLD BY.
THAT WOULD BE PUT TROUBLESOME
FOR ME OF FOR FOR THEIR SUPPORT --
BUT I APPRECIATE AT THE TABLE
HOPE THAT YOU GET THE READ THE
FULL OF OF FOR CCA'S TO MAKE
SURE THAT MY COMMUNITY CAN HAVE
THE CHOICE THEY'RE SEEKING RIGHT
NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTERBERMAN. FOR YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR --
AND SENATOR DODD I'LL JUST
QUICKLY ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH A
LOT THAT WERE MADE PRIOR TO ME --
IN PARTICULAR ON THE CCA'S YOU
95% OF MY DISTRICT IS COVERED BY
CITY IS THE OTHER 5% IS GOVERNED
BY MUNICIPALLY OWNED UTILITY --
SO IF THAT CAN'T GET WORKED OUT
THEN I WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL MOVING FORWARD --
I'M WILLING TO SUPPORT IT TODAY --
AND LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
YOU WORKOUT ON THAT AS WELL AS
ON THE RATE PAYER A CONCERNS
THAT WERE EXPRESSED BY ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND AND YOU'RE
HOPEFULLY EVEN.
ONCE THEN RESULT IS HAS BEEN
IMPROVED ALL HAVE IT --
THE ABILITY TO SUPPORT IT AGAIN
MOVING FORWARD THINK HE'S
[inaudible]
MISTER COOLEY.
I'VE GOT QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
AMENDMENTS BUT MY GENERAL VIEW
IN THIS AREA I THINK IS THAT THE
PUBLIC.
WILL GO ALONG WITH SAFETY IF
THEY FEEL THERE'S A REASONABLE
SHARON OF THE PAIN.
I'M CONCERNED THAT THE
SHAREHOLDERS ARE NOT NECESSARILY.
ON THE HOOK.
EVEN NO THEY MAKE THE INVESTMENT
THEY STAND TO GAIN BASED ON
THEIR INVESTMENT --
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHERE WE'RE PUTTING RATES THAT
THE RATE STRUCTURE OTHER
RATEPAYERS.
BUT THE SHAREHOLDER SORT OF OUR
ENSLAVED FROM THE OFFICE SUITE
DEAL IF YOU'RE A SHAREHOLDER
HERE.
YOU GENERALLY YOU PUT UP YOUR
CAPITAL YOU TAKE YOUR RISK AND
YOU GET A RETURN.
AND HERE THIS WOULD BE REMOVING
NAY.
HUGE RISK COMPONENT FROM THAT
CAPITAL INVESTMENT BY
SHAREHOLDER.
AND ARM IN GENERAL I THINK THAT.
THE REVIEWS BY THE PUBLIC WOULD
BE SKATING.
IF THEY SEE THEIR RATES GOING UP
AND IT COMES OUT THAT THE
SHAREHOLDERS WERE SORT OF
INSULATED FROM SHARON THAT.
AND THEN SIDE JUST A GENERALIZED
OBSERVATION THAT GIVES ME SOME
CONCERN HERE.
THE MORE PARTICULAR THING IS I
READ THE ANALYSIS AND THE
ACCORDING TO YOU WHEN YOU ANY
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS JUST LAST
DECEMBER A P. YOU SEE PROCESS
COMPLETED ITSELF [inaudible]
ESTABLISHING --
A STATE WIDE MAP OF HIGH FLYER
THREAT DISTRICTS HF TD'S.
WHICH TRIED TO LOOK AT THE STATE
AND SYSTEMATIC WAY I GUESS AND
IDENTIFY WHERE THE HIGH FIRE
THREAT AREAS.
THIS IS SIX MONTHS OLD THIS BODY
OF WORK.
WHICH WOULD SEEM TO SAY THERE
ARE SOME JUST SOME EFFORT TO
KINDA LOOK AROUND CALIFORNIA C.
WORST DROUGHT HIGH WEARS LOW.
AS I READ THE AUTHOR'S AMENDMENT
NUMBER.
ONE THE SUMMARY PROVIDE THE CPUC
SHOW CONSIDERADA CAN ACOSTA
PROPORTION THE BENEFITS OF SOME
PAGES ANALYSIS. TO EACH RATE
CLASS AND CLIMATE REGION.
IN WHICH YOU PROVE INVESTORS
PREMADE.
AND AND THAT PHRASE CLIMATE ZONE
APPEARS IN THE AMENDMENT THIS
PROPOSER NUMBER.
ONE I UNDERSTAND WHAT CLIMATE
ZONES REFERRING TO AND DOES THAT
BEAR A RELATIONSHIP. TO THE P.
UC'S WORK ON HIGH FIRE THREAT
DISTRICTS.
I I JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
CLIMATE ZONE MEANS.
IN RELATION TO THE EXISTING WORK.
JEFF YESTERDAY ABOUT WHAT IS
THAT THE THIS DIRECTION ONE WHO
ARE ADDRESS THE BUT THAT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THE HIGH FIRE
THROUGHOUT [inaudible]
DISTRICTS.
OKAY MISTER CHAIR IF I CAN
RESPOND TO THAT QUESTION --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
THE COMMISSION ALREADY USES A
SET OF CLIMATE ZONES.
SEC BASELINE RATES --
AND THERE BECAUSE YOU KNOW SOME
AREAS THE STATE ARE HARDER THAN
OTHERS SOME AREAS A COOLER THEY
HAVE DIFFERENT WEATHER.
AND SO TO SET A BASELINE USAGE
RATES THE COMMISSION HAS A
SERIES OF CLIMATE ZONES AND SO
WE AND WE SPECIFICALLY AND
INTENTIONALLY ADOPTED.
AN EXISTING STRUCTURE SO THAT WE
WOULDN'T BE INVENTING ANY NEW WE
ALSO WOULDN'T CRANNY THE
ADDITIONAL UNCERTAINTY OR
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN.
AND IT BE USING SOMETHING THAT.
EVERYBODY AT THE P. YOU SEEN
KNOWS WHAT IT MEANS --
AND THEY ARE RELEVANT --
TO THE DIFFERENT GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS IN THE STATE.
HOUSES CORRESPOND TO THE HIGH
FIRE THREAT DISTRICTS TO NEW
WORK OF THE P. UC --
IT THE REALITY IS THAT WOULD
SEEM TO RELATE TO THE COST IF
YOU YES FOR SURE --
AND WHAT WE SAW WITH THE NEW
MAPS IS AN AWFUL LOT OF THE
STATE IS A HIGH FIRE RISKS KNOWN
AT THIS POINT --
AND SO MOST OF THE CLIMATE ZONES
WILL PROBABLY HAVE HIGH FIRE
RISK IN THEM --
THAT'S THE REALITY WE FACE RIGHT
NOW.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEY HAVE --
EQUAL RISK OR THE COST SHOULD BE
SHARED EQUALLY OR INVESTMENT
SHOULD BE SHARED EQUALLY.
BUT PART OF THE AMENDMENT THAT
WAS PROPOSED TODAY.
IS TO CORRELATE WHERE THE
INVESTMENTS ARE MADE --
WITH WHO'S PAYING FOR THEM SO
THAT PEOPLE HAVE A REAL CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP.
AND AS YOU SAID IN A PEOPLE
GOING TO PAY FOR SAFETY THAT ARE
GETTING --
AND WE WANTED.
CAPITALIZE ON THE FACT
[inaudible]
CABLE [inaudible]
ON IF YOU [inaudible]
WHICH KILEY.
I WANTED TO GET A LITTLE MORE
CLARITY ON THIS DISPUTE OVER THE
LIABILITY STANDARD SO WE HEARD
FROM THE PROPONENTS THAT THEY'RE
STILL GONNA BE A NEGLIGENCE
STANDARD AYE IN COURT AND THE
RESPONSE FROM THE WITNESS --
FROM TURN IS THAT --
MOST OF THOSE CASES OF COURSE
THAT'S TRUE KIND OF IN ANY KIND
OF LITIGATION AND I YOU KNOW THE
THE LIABILITY STANDARD AT PARIS
ON NOT ON THE TERMS OF THE
SETTLEMENT SO.
COULD YOU JUST MAKE IT A LITTLE
MORE I STILL MORE EXPLICITLY WHY
YOU THINK THAT HAVING AYE AYE
NEGLIGENCE STANDARD IN --
IN THE CONTEXT OF A COURT
PROCEEDING AS OPPOSED TO A CPUC
PROCEEDING IS IN A SUFFICIENTLY --
POWERFUL LEVER TO INDUCE --
EFFICIENCY IF YOU MEASURES
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
IF I MAY UM FINDER SENATE THE
QUESTION I DON'T.
KNOW THAT WOULD MAKE A STATEMENT
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THE
NEGLIGENCE STANDARD SHOULD BE.
CHANGED OR THE USE OF THE
NEGLIGENCE STANDARD SHOULD BE
CHANGED I THINK MY COMMENT WAS
THAT AT LEAST UNDER CURRENT LAW.
THERE'S A NEGLIGENCE STANDARD
THAT.
CAN BE USED IN COURT BUT IF THE
CPC THE STANDARD IS --
IS -- ONE OF
PRUDENCE.
WHETHER YOU TO ACT PRUDENTLY OR
NOT AND SELL MY REFERENCE THE
WORD NEGLIGENCE IN THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS.
WAS THAT THE IMPACT OF THAT
AMENDMENT WOULD ONLY BE ON IN
COURT LITIGATION AS OPPOSED TO
IS THE PRECEDING THE CPUC.
AND MISTER CHAIR IF I COULD --
RESPOND TO THAT.
THE COMMISSION FINDS NEGLIGENCE.
ALL THE TIME.
EDISON WAS FOUND NEGLIGENT FOR
ITS HANDLING OF THE SENATE KNOW
FREE --
STEAM GENERATOR FAILURE.
P. GINNY WAS FOUND NEGLIGENT BY
THE PC FOR THE EXPLOSION IN SAN
BRUNO.
SO IT'S SIMPLY NOT THE CASE THAT
NEGLIGENCE REFERS ONLY TO A
COURT PROCEEDING IT'S SOMETHING
THE COMMISSION DOES AND HAS DONE
IN THE PAST AND YOU KNOW IF
NECESSARY I PRESUME WILL
CONTINUE TO DO IN THE FUTURE SO
THE THAT.
DICHOTOMY THAT'S BEEN PRESENTED
HERE JUST IS NOT ACCURATE MISTER
CHAIRMAN IF IT ENDED IN ADDITION
TO THAT THE EXAMPLE THAT WAS
GIVEN EARLIER BY THE TURN.
WITNESS STATING THAT IF.
THE UTILITY HAD BEEN NOTIFIED
THAT THERE WAS A PARKING POWER
LINE AND THEY DID NOTHING THAT
THIS BILL WOULD EXEMPT THEM.
I WOULD BRING YOUR ATTENTION TO
PAGE.
FIFTEEN LINES FIVE THROUGH SIX
WHAT SPECIFICALLY STATES THAT
ONE OF THE DISQUALIFIER SO
UTILITY.
WOULD BE IF THEY HAD ADVANCE
NOTICE OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES CAN
CONSTITUTING NONCOMPLIANCE.
SO THE EXAMPLE EGGS THE
IDENTICAL EXAMPLE THAT WAS GIVEN
IS EXPLICITLY PROHIBITED IN THE
BILL [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
NOW WE'VE TALKED IN.
TRY TO RESOLVE A I ONLY SIR ONE
OF THOSE [inaudible]
YOUR COMMITMENT [inaudible]
HERE.
FOR IF YOU'RE WILLING.
TO CAN YOU THAT WORK AS YOU
AGREED TWO AND THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF ISSUE FORTY TAKEN INTO
YOUR BILL.
FROM PART OF THAT WORKING GROUP
ON THIS PERKS --
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS FROM
HER BILL IS THAT IT DOES HAVE
BEEN AGREED TO AND YOU'VE TAKEN
THOSE.
AT THIS TIME OR YOU'RE ABOUT TO
TAKE THOSE ABOUT THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS --
THAT I HAVE READ INCORPORATE
THOSE.
AND I COMMIT YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH A GROUP TO AND AND MANY OF
THEM MAKE THE BILL BETTER MANY
OF THOSE --
REFINEMENTS HAVE NOT BEEN FULLY --
THAT IT OR SO SOLIDIFIED.
WITH EVERYONE AT THIS POINT YOU
HAVE A COMMITMENT.
ARE YOU OR WOULD YOU MAKE A
COMMITMENT TO MAKE SURE TO THE
OTHER MEMBERS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
FULLY --
APPRISED OF ALL OF THOSE THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE.
DIRECTLY WORKING WITH THOSE
COMMITTEES MEMBERS.
LOOK I WANT TO WORK WITH
EVERYBODY THAT WALKS YOU KNOW
THAT THEY ARE NOT REALLY AWARE
OF TO ASSEMBLY WORKING GROUPS
ARE THAT THERE WAS THERE WAS A
HOLDING GROUP AND THERE WAS THE
BURKE.
SO WE HAD TO THEIR THEM MOVING
FORWARD --
IT WITH RESPECT TO THAT --
IS THERE ALSO AN EXPRESSED COULD
COMMITMENT THAT IF THIS BILL.
FACE IS CONTINUAL ONSLAUGHT
FACES WHAT IF IT CONTINUES TO
FACE CONTINUE ONSLAUGHT.
THERE'S A WILLINGNESS ON YOUR
PART TO STAND DOWN ON THIS BILL.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO DO THAT
SO THAT WE COULD TAKE IT UP AT
THE BEGINNING OF NEXT YEAR.
YOU KNOW I'M NOT GONNA.
LET ORIGIN TO ANOTHER TO MAKE
THAT COMMIT UP COMMITMENT HERE
TODAY --
THAT MAYBE SOMETHING THAT I'M
GONNA BE ASKED TO DO BY --
THE COMMITTEE.
IF THE BIPARTISAN COMMITTEE --
YOU KNOW WHO OF BURKE AND AND
FLORA --
WORD TO OPINE AND THAT --
IN THAT FASHION I WOULD TAKE
THAT VERY SERIOUSLY AND WE'LL BE
TO SAVE THAT IF THAT'S WHAT THEY
WANTED ME TO DO ON THAT I WOULD
[inaudible]
YEAH OKAY.
THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE BECAUSE
I'M NOT GONNA SPEAK FOR MY OTHER
FELLOW MEMBERS HERE --
BUT THAT WOULD BE THE DIFFERENCE
FOR ME.
BECAUSE I I'VE TAKEN IS VERY
SERIOUS COMMITTED A GREAT DEAL
OF MY TIME A STEP BY.
INTO WORKING WITH EVERYONE AND
I'M WILLING.
TO WALK DOWN THE ROAD A LITTLE
FARTHER WITH YOU.
AND HELP MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
SO WE CAN HAVE A REASONABLE AND
RESPONSIBLE SAID A SOLUTIONS.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE SO ALSO TAKE
THAT AS A COMMITMENT FROM THE UK
AND I'LL TAKE THAT.
AND I WORK WITH THE IF THAT'S
WHAT IT TAKES TO GET THIS
PACKAGE DONE AND RIGHT JUST WAY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ANY ADDITIONAL OUR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
[inaudible]
SENATOR ALL.
CLOSED OUT FOR YOU THEN AND A
COUPLE COMMENTS --
ONE I APPRECIATE --
THE OFFICE AMENDMENTS YOU
BROUGHT FORWARD HERE AND I
APPRECIATE THE MANNER WHICH YOU
APPROACH THIS ISSUE CLEARLY
THERE SEVERAL PIECES OF
LEGISLATION WORKING THEIR WAY
THROUGH OUR PROCESS.
ARE THIS IS A LARGE AND
COMPLICATED ISSUE --
AS IT PERTAINS TO THE DISCUSSION
WE JUST HAD HERE TODAY COMMITTEE
IT'S ALSO ISSUE WHERE WE'RE NOT
SHORT ON HYPOCRISY AT TIMES.
ARE THERE RETIREMENT COST
CONTAINMENT WE TALK ABOUT --
SAFETY --
WHEN IT COMES?
TO POTENTIALLY SHIFTING
LIABILITY FROM.
SHAREHOLDERS TERROR RATEPAYERS
BICU TO REFORM NETWORK AND
OTHERS ARE FIRST IN LINE TO
RAISE THOSE CONCERNS.
WHEN IT COMES TO SHIFTING?
HYDRO COULD COST UNDER.
CENTRAL VALLEY FOLKS
[inaudible]
THERE ABSENT --
THERE ARE COST SHIPS ALL OVER.
UTILITY POLICY AND AND YOU'VE
GOT A COMPLICATED --
OBJECTIVE IN TRYING TO ADDRESS
THE VARYING INTERESTS OF THE
MANY MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
HERE MISTER GALLAGHER AND I BOTH
SHARE A LARGER CULTURAL
COMMUNITIES --
I WOULD POINT.
YOU KNOW TO HIS COMMENTS ABOUT
SHIFTING COST BURDEN ON SAFETY --
TO SHIFTING COST BURDEN TO THOSE
OF US THAT LIVE IN LESS
TEMPERATE CLIMATES.
RIGHT IF I BUILD MY HOUSE IN A
HIGH RISK FIRE [inaudible]
DISTRICT --
EVERYBODY SHOULD SHARE IN THE
COST IF I BUILT MY HOUSE IN A
HOT CLIMATE --
ONLY I SHOULD BEAR THE COST.
THOSE ARE NOT EQUITABLE.
OTHER AND INTELLECTUALLY
CONSISTENT POLICY OBJECTIVES AND
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE ON THAT
WHAT I ALSO THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE ON IS THAT SAFETY.
AND COST CONTAINMENT NEED TO BE
THE PRIORITIES --
OVERALL I THINK FROM ALL SIDES
ON HOW WE BALANCE THAT COMMITS
pDIFFICULT OBJECTIVE --
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
MOVE FORWARD I THINK THE
COMMITTEE I AS A WHOLE THROUGH
THEIR COMMENTS.
INDICATES ITS REPORT WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH.
A AND I TO SAFETY BUT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS DIALOGUE
ON TOP SHIPS AND CONTAINMENT AND
SO ON AND SO FORTH.
SO I APPRECIATE THE WAY DON'T
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENTS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE --
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO MAKE
AMENDMENTS CLEARLY AS THIS BILL
CAME OUT A PREVIOUS COMMITTEES
WORK WASN'T FULLY DOWN AND YOU
CONTINUE THAT WORKS I APPRECIATE
THAT.
AND THEY WILL HAVE A AYE
RECOMMENDATION FROM ME WILL KEEP
AN EYE -- ON
THIS BILL AS IT MOVES FORWARD AS
WELL AS OTHER PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AS WELL AS OUR
COLLECTIVE INTERACTION WITH THE
WORKING GROUPS ON THE OTHER
COMMITTEE JURISDICTIONS AND
COMMITTEES THAT ARE WORKING ON
THIS TOPIC.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN COME TO A
CONCLUSION THAT IS MORE
INTELLECTUALLY CONSISTENT AND
LESS HYPOCRITICAL THAT OUR
CURRENT ENERGY POLICY TODAY.
WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THIS IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL GREG AYE GRAY AYE
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
SO THEY ARE OCCURRING.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I'VE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO.
LEVINE.
LIVING AYE LOW.
LOW AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS [inaudible]
WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT SENATOR WILL ON
THE THE ROLE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS TIME WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DO WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GRAY AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I'VE BONTA [inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
DALY AYE DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LIVING HIGH.
LOW.
LOW AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS [inaudible]
WALDRON.
WALDRON I THINK.
OKAY THE CONSENT COUNTERS
ADOPTED AT THIS TIME MEMBERS
WERE GONNA MOVE TO ITEM EIGHT ON
THE AGENDA S. B. TWELVE OH FIVE
AND WELCOME SENATOR HILL.
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I HAVE A
VERY SIMPLE BILL FOR YOU TODAY.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT WAS VERY
SIMPLE CREATED AND I WHAT IT FOR
TO THIS ONE I THINK THE
FIREFIGHTERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE FOR PUTTING THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE.
EVERY DAY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF IT
WOULDN'T SUPPORT.
OKAY WE HAVE A MISTER CHAIRMAN
BRUCE NANCY CHINA SUSPEND ALSO
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION --
OUR LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
DEPEND ON FIRE AGENCIES TO HELP
KEEP OUR KIDS AND OUR EMPLOYEES
SAY FROM RISK ASSOCIATED WITH --
FIRE AND BUILDING CODE ISSUES
THINGS LIKE THAT --
WE SUPPORT THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
IT IS A IT WOULD HELP FACILITATE
COMMUNICATION TO ENSURE THAT THE
GOVERNING BOARDS OF THOSE FIRE
AGENCIES ARE AWARE IF THEIR
INSPECTORS ARE HAVING ANY
DIFFICULTY MEETING THOSE.
ANNUAL INSPECTION REQUIREMENTS.
PUBLIC SAFETY SO WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORT A
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BACK TO THE MEMBERS.
MOTION AND SECOND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OKAY AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA [inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA AYE
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE HIGH LOW.
LOW AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
THOSE AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
OKAY SIR THAT BILLS OUT.
AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO RETURN ITEM SIX ON THE AGENDA
SB TEN SEVENTY SIX NOT WHICH
SENATOR HILLS GOING TO PRESENT
THAT FOR CENTER HERTZBERG THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR A
THANKS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
HERTZBERG --
HE'S HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
IN HERE EXCEPT IN THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU VERY IT WOULD ACCEPT
THE MEMBERS THANK YOU.
SUPPORT OPPOSITION APP.
PATRICK ALTER THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
WE HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL
BUT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
ALTERNATE STAFF APPRECIATE THE
MOMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BACK TO THE MEMBERS.
CHINO QUESTIONS THIS IS --
DO PASS AS AMENDED APPROPRIATION
NUMBER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL GRAY AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOLEY AYE.
COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY AYE DALY AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY LACKEY AYE
LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
THAT BILLS OUTSIDERS THANK YOU.
THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
MOVE TO ITEM NINE ONOUR AGENDA
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY THREE AND
ASK CENTER BRADFORD --
TO PLEASE APPROACH OF PRESENT
HIS BILL WELCOME SENATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE AS STATED TO
PRESENT.
S. B. TWELVE EIGHTY THREE LET ME
FIRST START BY THINKING THIS --
CHAIRMAN AND HIS STAFF FOR THE
WORK THAT WE'VE PUT IN.
TO GET US TO A POINT OF
AGREEMENT --
SP TWELVE EIGHTY THREE IS AIMED
AT SUPPORTING THE GROWTH OF THE
CRAFT BREWERIES ACROSS OUR STATE
WHILE ALSO ENSURING THAT BROUGH
POP RESTAURANT TO HEAR. TO THE
GUIDELINES AND GOALS OF OUR
STATE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOL
BEVERAGE CONTROL OR BETTER KNOWN
AS AB C. CALIFORNIA'S TO BIRTH
PLACE.
IN AMERICA FOR CRAFT BREWING
MOVEMENT IN A LEADER IN THIS
FLOURISHING INDUSTRY TODAY
BREWERIES CALL CALIFORNIA HOME --
THEN -- ANY
OTHER STATE IN THE NATION --
IT GENERATES ABOUT WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR MISTER COOLER SECOND
FROM MISTER GIPSON.
AND WE UNDERSTAND YOU'LL BE
SUCKED IN THE AMENDMENT I'VE
STEPPED TO THE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT.
HI I'M CAREY BURGER THE CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER OF
ARTISANAL BREWERS COLLECTIVE.
WE BELIEVE THAT BREWPUB
RESTAURANTS ARE IMPORTANT PART
OF THE CRAFT BEER AND
HOSPITALITY LANDSCAPING
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT THIS BILL HELPS TO
FURTHER --
THOSE ESTABLISHMENTS AND HELP
THEM CONFORM TO THE REQUIREMENTS
IN THE STATE THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING ABOUT TO
THE MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE THE MOTION
AND A SECOND THIS IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GRAY.
AYE AYE AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
AND CONSTANT.
THAT'S THE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY EYES BERMAN
[inaudible]
I BONTA.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER AYE DALY AYE DALY AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON HI GLORIA.
GLORIA I JONES SAWYER.
Q. HAVE JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE HIGH LOW.
LOW AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS AYE GLOWING AYE
WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT SOONER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
OKAY AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO MOVE TO NUMBER TEN ON
YOUR AGENDA --
SP FOURTEEN KNOW A CENTER PAN
WELCOME.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS --
SP FOURTEEN OH EIGHT AS A MAKES
TO CHANGES TO THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE AFTER THE PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S FROM NON FIRE SAFE
CIGARETTES.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIVE PASSAGE
OF THE CALIFORNIA CIGARETTE FIRE
SEEKING FIREFIGHTER PROTECTION
ACT CIGARETTES SO THAT OUR STATE
HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO MEET
CERTAIN IGNITION STANDARDS.
THESE --
STANDARDS ARE KNOWN AS REDUCING
THIS A STRENGTH OF FIRE SAFE
CIGARETTES ARE DESIGNED TO
EXTINGUISH FOR NOT BEING
ACTIVELY SMOKED.
PRIOR TO PASSAGE OF THE ACT
CIGARETTES WERE THE LEADING
CAUSE OF FIRED THAT IN THE
UNITED SEE TEACHERS OVER A
THOUSAND LIVES LOST FOUR HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IN ANNUAL.
AND DIRECT PROPERTY DAMAGE
ANNUALLY.
PASSAGE OF STATE LAWS
PROHIBITING THESE NON FIRE SAFE
CIGARETTES BELIEVE TO BE ONE THE
PRINCIPAL REASONS FOR THE 30%
DECLINE IN SMOKING RELATED FIRED
THAT'S WE SAW NATIONWIDE.
OF GOOD HAVE A A MOTION A SECOND
SENATOR ALRIGHT EXCELLENT SO
BASICALLY S. B. FORTINO IT WOULD
MAKE A TECHNICAL CHANGE BY
DEEMING NON FIRE SAFE CIGARETTES
THIS CONTRABAND PER SE.
THIS ALL OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
NEARLY SEIZE THESE UNSAFE
PRODUCTS AND SECOND S. BEFORE TO
ELIMINATE EXCEPTION THAT ALLOWS
THAT CURLY THIS LAW ALLOWS NOT
FIRE SAFE CIGARETTES INTO
CALIFORNIA JUST AS LONG AS A MAN.
BACK TO CLAIM THEIR INTENDED FOR
ANOTHER STATE PRODUCTS BUT THAT
EXPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU ANY --
TESTIMONY OF SPORT.
ASKING AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
BIRDS OF THE COMMITTEE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL RADICALLY
CHARGED.
WITH THE OFFICE OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL HEAVY ADVERSARY --
ON BEHALF OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE I WOULD LIKE TO
THINK SENATOR PAMPERS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE AND FOR
AUTHORING SP FOURTEEN OH EIGHT A
BILL THAT ALLOWS LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO SEIZE NON FIRE SAFE.
CIGARETTES --
NOT FIRE SAFE CIGARETTES AS A
SENATOR PAN SAID POSE A
SIGNIFICANT FIRE ARRESTEES ARE
CIGARETTES THAT STATE NIGHT EVEN
WHEN NOT IN ACTIVE USE AND
PERCENT A HIGH RISK OF STARTING
FIRES --
THOUGH CURRENTLY BANNED IN ALL
FIFTY STATES THESE PRODUCTS ARE
STILL BROUGHT INTO THE COUNTRY
VIA CALIFORNIA'S PORTS AND
AIRPORTS.
I QUICKLY S. B. FORTINO EIGHT
DOES TWO THINGS IT ALLOWS LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO SEIZE NON FIRE
SAFE CIGARETTES ARM BY DEFINING
THE MISS CONTRABAND PER SE
THEREBY ELIMINATING THE NEED.
FOR I'D NOTICE AND HEARING FOR
NURSING HEARING --
AND SECOND IT S. B. FOURTEEN
AWAY CLOSES A LOOPHOLE FOR
SELLERS OF NON FIRE SAFE
CIGARETTES WHO CLAIM THEIR
PRODUCTS.
ARE DEEMED FOR OUT OF STATE
MARKET AS A SENATOR PAN NOTED --
THIS OUT OF STATE EXCEPTION
DOESN'T.
MAKE SENSE ANYMORE BECAUSE OF
OUR AS OF AUGUST TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN IN ALL FIFTY STATES AND
THE DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA --
HAVE PASSED FIRE SAFETY LET
[inaudible]
ONI'M I'M JOINED TODAY BY MY
COLLEAGUE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL NORTH LA I'M --
WHO CAN'T WITH THAT --
WITH DOJ'S TOBACCO LITIGATION
AND ENFORCEMENT SECTION AND
SHE'S AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AYE WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
AFRICA ARE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE FIREFIGHTERS ASSOCIATION
WE WERE.
SOME OF THE ORIGINAL COSPONSORS
OF THE CORRUPTS LEGISLATION
THERE'S AGO THINKING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
DUG SERVERS ONLY HAVE A
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT.
OKAY TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE --
BRING IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND THIS IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL GRAY AYE GRAY I
THINK [inaudible]
BIGELOW NO [inaudible]
ACOSTA [inaudible]
ACOSTA I AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE BONTA [inaudible]
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY.
DALY AYE GALLAGHER [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON HI GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY
[inaudible]
LACKEY AREN'T.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON.
THAT BILLS OUT SENATOR GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH
[inaudible]
SECOND.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN I BELIEVE
YOU'RE GOING TO PRESENT FOR
MISTER GLAZIER I BELIEVE IN A
PRESENT --
S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ALREADY ON
THE FLOOR.
PLEASE DON'T MESS UP AT THIS
MOMENT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE
VOTE.
VERY GOOD I SEE YOU HAVE A
WITNESS HERE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ADD ON IS A REPORT [inaudible]
THERE.
TIM SMALL SIR --
WITH ONE INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
IS ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE --
TO THE IN THE TWO IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
SEEING.
NINE WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
GREAT AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
I BIGELOW AYE A CONSTANT FIGHT.
ACOSTA AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AYE WE ARE CURRY AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I DALY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON --
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS.
I WAS AYE WALDRON [inaudible]
LOW AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER SENATOR WIENER ARE YOU
WERE UP NEXT WITH YOUR BILL S.
B. [inaudible]
NINE OH FIVE I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR HEARING THIS BILL.
MOVEMENT WILL [inaudible]
I THOUGHT --
S. B. I NINE OH FIVE AND I WERE
ALL HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS OF THANK
YOU.
FOR AYE THOSE --
THIS BILL I THINK --
FOR ALMOST ALL OF YOU SHOULD BE
FAMILIAR BECAUSE YOU HEARD A AND
PASSED IT OUT LAST YEAR.
IN A BROADER FORM THIS IS A BILL
NOW AND NOT REQUIRE A LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES --
WHETHER AND TO WHAT EXTENT TO
ALLOW THEIR BARS NIGHTCLUBS AND
OR RESTAURANTS BUT NOT LIQUOR
STORES AYE TO EXTEND SERVICE
HOURS TO FOUR AM --
LAST YEAR THE BILL APPLY TO ALL
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA UMPIRE
I LEARNED THAT THERE ARE TIMES
AS MUCH AS CITY SOMETIMES DON'T
WANT TO TAKE AWAY THE LOCAL
CONTROL.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN I SOME
CITIES DON'T WANT TO RECEIVE
LOCAL CONTROL EVEN THAT WAS A
SURPRISE TO ME --
AND SO WE ARE ABOUT BROUGHT THIS
GO BACK A LIMITED TO THE SEVEN
CITIES WHO HAVE SAID WHO CITY
COUNCIL ARE MAYOR HAS SAID TO US.
HOW WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THIS
FLEXIBILITY CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW
HAS A ONE SIZE FITS ALL?
APPROACH FROM NINETEEN THIRTY
FIVE THAT ALL LIQUOR SALES SHALL
AND THE TWO AM WHETHER YOU'RE IN
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES --
OR IN THE MOST RURAL PART OF
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T MATTER AT ALL
SO IT'S DOWN TO TWO A. M. --
DOES NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THAT
NIGHT LIFE IS DIFFERENT IN
DIFFERENT UP PARTS OF OUR STATE
AND WE WANT OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO
EVALUATE AND DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES.
WHETHER TO GO LATER NIGHTLIFE IS
A SIGNIFICANT --
NOT JUST ECONOMIC DRIVER BUT
CULTURAL DRIVER --
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE SHOULD
EMBRACE IT AND ALLOW IT TO A
FLOURISH --
WE HAVE --
BUILT AND WE WITH THIS
COMMITTEESHELP LAST YEAR
SIGNIFICANT GUARDRAILS AROUND
THIS BILL --
FOR A CITY THAT WANTS TO EXTEND --
THE CITY COUNCIL HAS TO GO
THROUGH A PUBLIC PROCESS AND
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS NOTIFY
DEVOURING.
I JURISDICTIONS COME UP WITH THE
PUBLIC SAFETY AND A
TRANSPORTATION PLAN --
AND THEN SUBMIT ITS PLAN TO A.
B. C. FOR SIGN OFF --
AND THERE'S THIS IS A A VERY
PROCESS INTENSIVE AYE ENDEAVOR
IT IS A FIVE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM.
ASSUME WE CAN REEVALUATE IT UPON
THE EXPIRATION.
ALL OF THE PILOT PROGRAM --
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE OUT WITH ME --
TODAY IS MISS ALREADY S. FROM
TELL TRAVEL AND AYE NICOLO
DELUCA FROM THE CITY.
OF OAKLAND WHICH IS ONE OF THE
SEVEN CITIES AND THE PILOT AND
BY THE WAY THE CITIES ARE
OAKLAND SACRAMENTO SAN FRANCISCO
LOS ANGELES LONG BEACH.
WEST HOLLYWOOD AND PALM SPRINGS
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
I'M WAITING AND WAITING FOR THE
LETTER [inaudible]
SILVA.
OKAY TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
COULDN'T AFTERNOON CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MUCH OUR S. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TRIAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO KNOWN AS CAO
TROUBLE I'M IN SHOCK SUPPORTIVE
S. B. NINE OF FIVE IF YOU WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AS WELL
AS A SENATOR FOR HIS WORK ON
THIS ISSUE.
I'M AS THE LEADING VOICE FOR THE
TOURISM INDUSTRY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE REALLY LOVE IT
WHEN TOURISTS COME VISIT OUR
STAYS ON BOTH DOMESTIC AND
INTERNATIONAL --
HOWEVER WE HAVE REALIZED THAT WE
ARE AT A DISADVANTAGE WITH SIR
AND I'M DESTINATION CITIES WHEN
IT COMES.
TO ITEMS SUCH AS ATTRACTING
CONVENTIONS I'M AND OTHER EVENTS --
WEBELIEVE THIS WILL STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION TO HELP US WITH
THAT DISADVANTAGED AND AND WE
ASK HERE ABOUT THANK YOU.
CHAIRPERSON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE NICOLO DELUCA BEHALF
OF OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY SHAFT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SENATOR
SAID THIS IS A PILOT PROGRAM --
THERE ALSO BE EXTENSIVE LOCAL
DISCUSSION OF COURSE WITH OUR PT
AND OUR NEIGHBORS --
BUT MORE POORLY THIS IS A MAJOR
ECONOMIC DRIVER FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES THE RESTAURANTS IN
THE BARS SO FOR AS AN EXAMPLE
THEY UP FOX THEATRE.
IT'S SURROUNDED BY THIRTY BARS
AND RESTAURANTS IN THE CHAU GETS
OUT TO BE AROUND ELEVEN TWELVE
AT NIGHT.
THE ADDITIONAL TIME IT'S GONNA
BE A HUGE BOON TO THOSE OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I THINK YOU.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
BACKING MENTALITY BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD IN
SUPPORT.
DAVID JONES ABOUT FROM THEIR
GIRL STEINBERG IN SUPPORT.
MATT BROWN MBF THE TEAMSTERS AND
UNITE HERE IN SUPPORT.
JOHN CALL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT.
I HAVE LOW DOWN PER PERSON IN
UBER AND SUPPORT.
MIKE MONEY GONNA BE HAVE THE
CITY OF OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
OKAY.
A DISH OF TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WILL MOVE TO
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THERE WERE.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN.
ON THE LEFT OVER HERE AND WILL
MOVE TO OUR RIGHT SO PROCEED
WITH YOUR TESTIMONY SIR.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FROM ON COST
OF AUNT PROFESSOR SAN FRANCISCO
STATE UNIVERSITY.
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY THAT --
WE ARE --
PRESENTED WITH WHAT IS A GOLD
STANDARD IN RESEARCH IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE IMPACT OF THIS BILL
WILL BE.
THIS BILL --
WILL LEAD TO INCREASED HARM BOTH
IN TERMS OF CAR WRECKS --
AND ALL ALL OTHER REALLY OR
TYPES OF HARMS --
THIS WAS FOUND BY THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL THEY USE THE
HIGHEST STANDARDS THE COULD BE
USED FOR RESEARCH ON WHAT THE
IMPACT WOULD BE OF KEEPING BARS
OPEN AN EXTRA TWO HOURS.
THEY LOOKED AT EVERY MAJOR STUDY
THAT HAVE BEEN DONE THAT SO THEY
COULD POSSIBLY CONSIDER AND WHAT
THEY FOUND CONCLUSIVELY IS THAT
KEEPING THE BARS OPEN ANOTHER
TWO HOURS WILL HARM.
THE COMMUNITIES BOTH IN AND NEAR
OF WHERE THOSE PARTS ARE KEPT
OPEN.
NOW I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
COMMITTEE IS PURSUE PRESENT IN
THE PAST WITH --
A PIECE OF PAPER --
THAT SHOWED THE HOURS TO CERTAIN
STATES HAVE FOR OUR HOW LONG
THEIR BAR STAY OPEN AND THE RATE
OF ALCOHOL RELATED CAR CRASHES.
A THAT IS NOT RESEARCH AT ALL
THAT DOES NOT PROVIDE ANY KIND
OF EVIDENCE THAT --
THERE IS NO HARM THE MATTER IS
VERY COMPLICATED THERE ARE MANY
FACTORS THAT EX THAT AFFECT HOW
ALCOHOL KEEPING BARS OPEN
AFFECTS THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
OF ITS NOT JUST THE BARS AT IT
IN THE STATES THAT WE ARE BEING
COMPARED TO THEY COULD HAVE
DIFFERENT PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS THEY COULD HAVE --
DIFFERENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
SYSTEMS THEY COULD HAVE
DIFFERENT SPEED LIMITS THE COULD
HAVE DIFFERENT LAWS ABOUT USING
DRUGS THERE'S ALL KINDS OF
THINGS THAT AFFECT THE STATE'S
RATE OF ALCOHOL RELATED CAR
CRASHES.
A BILL THAT SIMPLY COMPARES OR A
PIECE OF PAPER THAT SIMPLY --
SHOWS THE CAR CRASHES IN THE
STATE AND THE ALCOHOL --
THE LOSSES NOW LAKE MARS COULD
STAY OPEN DOESN'T SHOW YOU
ANYTHING AT ALL YOU HAVE SOLID
EVIDENCE FROM THE CDC FROM THE
HIGHEST RESEARCH YOU COULD
POSSIBLY HAVE.
THIS BILL WILL COST LIVES.
HI DOCTOR MARK HORTON --
I'M.
THE CHAIR AND OTHER HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE OF OF THE
COMMITTEE --
I'M A PEDIATRICIAN FORMER HEALTH
COUNTY OF ORANGE AND A FORMER
STATE HEALTH OFFICER AND
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH ON
HERE.
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
SIXTY ONE OPPOSITION A LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICER MEMBERS OF THE
HEALTH A HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE HUNDREDS OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL MEMBERS.
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC HEALTH
ASSOCIATION NORTH A PUBLIC
HEALTH ROLE VIS A VIS THE PUBLIC
POLICY DEVELOPMENT IS TO
CAREFULLY REVIEW THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE ALLOWING US TO ASSESS
THE POTENTIAL IMPACT.
ON THE CITIZENS OF CHANGES TO
PUBLIC POLICY BEING PROPOSED
THROUGH LEGISLATION AND TO
ENSURE THAT YOU S. LEGISLATORS
HAVE THE FACTS BEFORE MAKING A
DECISION.
THE POTENTIAL HEALTH IMPACT OF
NINE OH FIVE IS CLEAR.
OVER FORTY YEARS OF PEER
REVIEWED SCIENTIFIC DATA
CONFIRMS THAT EXTENDING ALCOHOL
SALES TO FOUR AM WOULD MEAN MORE
INTOXICATED DRIVERS ON THE ROAD.
MORE DO YOU AYE CRASHES MORE
PERSONAL INJURIES ER VISITS MORE
DEATHS MORE VIOLENT CRIME.
THIS HEALTH BURDEN WOULD BE BORN
NOT JUST BY THE RESIDENTS OF THE
PILOT COUNTIES BUT BY THOSE OF
SURROUNDING COUNTIES INTO WHICH
INTO WHICH LATE NIGHT DRINKERS
MAY TRAVEL.
YOUR JOB IS LEGISLATORS IS TO A
WAVE OF THIS POTENTIAL HEALTH
BURDEN AGAINST THE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS TO THE SPECIAL
INTERESTS.
SUPPORTING THE BILL INCLUDING
THE ALCOHOL INDUSTRY AND LOCAL
BUSINESSES SELLING ALCOHOL TO
CUSTOMERS INTO THE EARLY MORNING.
IN DOING SO I URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THAT PUBLIC HEALTH IS
NOT SIMPLY ANOTHER SPECIAL
INTEREST.
IT IS THE BEST EXPRESSION OF
SOCIETY'S INTEREST IN THE COMMON
GOOD.
IN ASSURING THE CONDITIONS IN
WHICH EVERY INDIVIDUAL CAN
ACHIEVE MAXIMUM HEALTH AS SUCH
WE BELIEVE THAT HEALTH
CONSIDERATIONS SHOULD ALWAYS
TRUMP THE FINANCIAL BENEFITS.
SPECIAL INTERESTS AND
CONSIDERING CHANGES IN PUBLIC
POLICY.
IT'S HEALTH VERSUS PROFITS
CHOICE SHOULD BE EASY NO ONE
NINE OH FIVE THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LYNN
BROWN I'M THE PROGRAM MANAGER
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT LIAISON FOR
MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING IN
SACRAMENTO.
MATT CALIFORNIA OPPOSES SENATE
BILL NINE ZERO FIVE CALIFORNIA
SHOULD RETAIN A UNIFORM BAR
CLOSING.
TIME TO HELP PREVENT BAR HOPPING
TO FIND ONE LAST DRINK AN
ESTABLISHMENT WITH A LEADER
CLOSING TIME.
WITH THIS BILL NEIGHBORING
CITIES COULD FACE A SPILL OVER
EFFECT IN INCREASED DEMAND ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO KEEP ROADS
SAFE.
WE'VE ALSO HEARD THE ARGUMENT
THAT EXTENDING BAR HOURS WOULD
ELIMINATE THE CROWDS OF PEOPLE
AND OF POTENTIAL RUSH.
OF DRUNK DRIVERS LEAVING THE
BARS AT TWO A. M..
QUITE FRANKLY OUR ROADS ARE
RELATIVELY UNOCCUPIED TO A. M.
AS COMPARED TO FOUR AND FIVE AM.
CALIFORNIA STILL HAD OVER ONE
THOUSAND FATALITIES ON OUR
ROADWAYS IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
DUE TO DUI CRASHES THAT'S A
SIXTEEN POINT 2% INCREASE OVER.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THIS
LEGISLATION WILL PUT FRESHLY
IMPAIRED DRIVERS ON THE ROAD AT
THE TIME OF DAY WHEN COMMUTERS.
CARPOOL TAKING CHILDREN TO
SCHOOL HIGHWAY WORKERS AND OTHER
TRAVELERS ARE BEGINNING TO FILL
OUR ROADWAYS.
AGAIN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
RESEARCH DOES NOT INDICATE THAT
EXTENDING HOURS WOULD MAKE US
SAFER.
RATHER THE RESEARCH SHOWS THE
OPPOSITE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THERE
WERE TEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
NINETY SEVEN PEOPLE.
KILLED ON OUR NATION'S HIGHWAYS
DUE TO DO YOU AYE CRASHES.
AN AVERAGE OF ONE ALCOHOL
IMPAIRED DRIVING FATALITY OCCURS
EVERY FIFTEEN MINUTES.
SO FOR EVERY FIFTY MINUTES THAT
WE SIT HERE.
SOMEONE IS BEING KILLED IN
IMPAIRED DRIVING CRASH.
AND REMEMBER THESE ARE JUST
NUMBERS THEY IS THERE'S ART
NUMBERS AT ALL THEY'RE HUMAN
BEINGS THEIR PEOPLE WITH
FAMILIES WITH FRIENDS WITH LOVED
ONES.
THERE PEOPLE LIKE YOU AND LIKE
ME.
THIS BILL HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF TRAGEDIES
ON CALIFORNIA'S ROADS MOTHERS
AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING
RESPECTFULLY URGES ARE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATORS TO VOTE
NO.
ON SENATE BILL NINE ZERO FIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CARSON BENEFITS FREDRICKSON
HERE FROM ALCOHOL JUSTICE --
THE FACT THAT EXTENDING LAST
CALL TIMES CAUSES HARM IS REALLY
NOT UP FOR DEBATE WE HAVE
RESEARCH INDEPENDENT AND PEER
REVIEWED FROM FOUR CONTINENTS
LOOKING AT HALF A CENTURY OF
DATA.
ALL THAT DEMONSTRATES THIS.
DISCUSSION STARTS BUT
IMPORTANTLY DOES NOT END WITH
ANNE MARIE CRASHES.
SO CALIFORNIA IS IN A PRETTY
MUCH ON THAT KNOWLEDGE CRASH
CRISIS ARE THE MOST RECENT ODS
REPORT HAD INTOXICATED TALLIES
UP 20% OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
THESE ARE VERY DRAMATIC ENDS TO
A NIGHT OUT AND THAT WE'LL SEE
MORE OF THEM WITH LITTLE LAST
CALL TIMES ACCORDING TO
INTERNATIONAL EVIDENCE
SYSTEMATICALLY REVIEWED BY OVER
A DOZEN AMERICAN PUBLIC HEALTH
EXPERTS.
AS THE CDC COMMITTEE THAT DOCTOR
CASTLE LAUNCHES REFERRING.
TO I IN THIS CASE COMMONSENSE
ALIGNS WITH THE RESEARCH BOTH
COMMONSENSE AND RESEARCH SHOW
THAT PARTY HOTSPOTS ATTRACT
PEOPLE EVEN IF THEY CAN'T BUDGET
FOR CAR SERVICE THEY WILL DRINK
MORE THAN IF THE BAR CLOSED IT.
TOO THERE WILL BE MORE EXHAUSTED
WHEN DRIVING HOME AND THAT WILL
LEAD TO MORE DE WISE AND MORE
CRASHES.
BUT PRESSURES ARE NOT THE ONLY
HARM THEY'RE NOT EVEN THE CHIEF
HARM.
THE EVIDENCE OF SPIKES IN
INJURIES AND CRIME IS
OVERWHELMING AYE WE'VE SEEN THIS
IN NEW YORK THERE'S A STUDY --
THAT THAT NEW YORK HAS THE SORT
OF LOCAL CONTROL STATE THAT WERE
SO.
SOSA I SEE AS AN IDEAL.
AND THERE THAT THAT EXTRA HOUR
OPEN AFTER ONE THE START EACH
EXTRA HOUR AFTER ONE A AND NEED
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE VIOLENT
CRIMES.
BELIEVE IT'S ALMOST FIVE PER.
HUNDRED THOUSAND THE TOTAL COST
OF THIS IS TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THIS AND AT THIS ANALYSIS DID
NOT INCLUDE NEW YORK CITY.
I YOU CAN LOOK --
ELSEWHERE CHEN IN NORWAY --
THERE WAS A PATCHWORK OF
EXTENDED RETRACTED LAST CALL
TIMES EVERY HOUR FUTURES
EXTENDED ADDED 17% OF THE RATE
OF ASSAULTS --
EVERY HOURS ATTRACTED DECREASED
ASSAULT BY 21% IN THE IN IN
AMSTERDAM WHICH A YOU KNOW MOST
WAS HE IS A GLOBAL CITY.
THEY THEY CREATED IN FACT
EXACTLY THE SAME KIND OF UP
PARTY ZONES THAT THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE AND SAW THAT THOSE RESULT
IN 34% INCREASE IN LATE NIGHT
AMBULANCE CALLS.
THESE FIGURES ARE JUST A SMALL
SAMPLE OF THE FORTY OR FIFTY
THAT OUR BY THE REFER TO BY
EXPERTS.
ALSO WITH THAT MIND WE WE WE
OBJECTED TO SOME OF THE SERB
MISUSE OF SCIENTIFIC TERMS IN
THIS BILL THIS IS NOT REALLY A
PILOT IT'S NOT REALLY LOCAL
CONTROL --
SO IN THIS ISSUE THE ENTIRE
POINT IS TO GET MORE PEOPLE TO
THE CITIES THAT HAVE LATE LAST
CALL TIMES AND TO GET THEM TO
SPEND MORE MONEY ON ALCOHOL.
PEOPLE THEN DRINK MORE GO BACK
HOME SOME OF THEM ARE DRUNK
SOMEWHERE A VIOLENT SOME CRASH
THE HARM TO THIS BILL DO NOT
STAY LOCAL.
THOUGH THE REVENUES CERTAINLY
WILL STILL STAY LOCAL --
NO HARMS AND BACKSPLASH OVER
ALTERING THE COMMUNITIES AND HOW
MANY SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES --
A PILOT IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
SMALL SCALE STUDY THAT LOOKED AT
IMPACTS AND HOW TO MITIGATE THEM.
THIS PILOT AFFECTS FIVE LARGEST
TEN CITIES IN CALIFORNIA AYE IF
YOU TAKE THEIR COMBINED CENSUS
AREAS OF THAT IS A ABOUT 76% OF
POPULATION.
IT DOESN'T SPECIFY HOW IT WILL
MEASURE HARM OR MITIGATE THE
HARMS THAT EMERGE IN A DEATHLY
DOES NOT BOTHER FUNDING DATA
COLLECTION OR ANALYSIS.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT
CALIFORNIA EXCEPTIONALISM MEANS
WERE IMMUNE TO ALCOHOL HARM
PLEASE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
STOP US RECKLESS EXPERIMENT IS
CALIFORNIA LIVE CALIFORNIAN
LIVES ON THE LINE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
OKAY WILL TAKE ADDITIONAL ON
TESTIMONY OPPOSITION.
YES OUR BRUCE LIVINGSTON AND
I'VE BEEN ASKED --
TO EXPRESS THE OPPOSITION OF
INSTITUTE FOR PUBLIC STRATEGIES
OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY AND BARBARY
COAST NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION.
OF SAN FRANCISCO.
SARAH COOLEY I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CALL POLICY LINES THINKING.
TOM RETREAT WITH CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON DR GERM COOLER
THE CALIFORNIA FRIDAY I
PARTNERSHIP REPRESENTING YOUNG
PEOPLE IN FIFTY OF OUR FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES WHO ARE CONCERNED
THAT THIS WILL BE GOOD FOR
BUSINESS BUT GOOD FOR BUSINESS
AND EMERGENCY ROOMS. FOR A. B.
C..
AND FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT SO WE
WOULD SUGGEST THIS IS NOT THE
BEST CHOICE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
A RIVER JAMES BUTLER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON ALCOHOL
PROBLEMS.
AND ALCOHOL NARCOTIC EDUCATION
FOUNDATION.
IN OPPOSITION.
THINK YOU TURN MEMBERS CHIANA
CITY DAY ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPERVISOR NAY
MALIA POSTS.
UP MARC CARLSON LUTHERAN OFFICE
OF PUBLIC POLICY IN OPPOSITION
THERE IS NO REVENUE ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS.
COSTS OF HARM ARE ENORMOUS.
I WORKED AS A STATE FIREFIGHTER
OVER THREE DECADES ATTENTION
OPERATOR.
I'VE SEEN AS A SEASONAL I'VE
SEEN FIRST HAND WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN OUR CARS OR TRUCKS HIT P.
GINNY POLLS --
AND I'VE SEEN FIRST HAND WHAT
HAPPENS JUST.
JUST AFTER THE BARS CLOSE WHEN
SOMEBODY'S GOING HOME IN NAY
GENTLY DRIFT INTO THE GRASS.
WITH A HOT MUFFLER THE END
RESULT DOES NOT LOOK GOOD AND IT
DOES NOT SMELL GOOD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FRED JONES I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
COME AND SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
WALL LAS MEMORIAS PROJECT LOS
ANGELES.
AS WELL AS THE WEST ALAMEDA
COUNTY ALCOHOL MARIJUANA AND
PRESCRIPTION DRUG COALITION IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR JUST ADVANCE ON
BEHALF OF LIFT APOLOGIZE AND
MISS THE US SUPPORT TESTIMONY
BUT LEFT ISN'T SUPPORT.
OKAY TO EVERY ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL GO AHEAD AND
BRING IT --
BACK TO THE MEMBERS FOR
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
IT GIVES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WAS CHAIRMAN
OF THIS IS TO THE AUTHOR TO EVER
CAN ANSWER HIS QUESTION.
I UNDERSTAND --
HAS A FIVE YEAR SUNSET IS THAT
TRUE THIS PART OF THE BILL AND
AFTER THE FIVE YEARS --
I'M ASSUMING GATHERING FACTS AND
INFORMATION WHAT IS THE PROCESS
IN WHICH THAT INFORMATION WILL
BE SHARED WITH THIS BODY.
LED SORT OF A BODY YES I THANK
YOU ASSEMBLYMAN --
SO AT THE END OF THE FIVE YEAR
PILOT THERE WILL BE A REPORT --
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
LEGISLATURE WILL THEN EVALUATE
WHETHER TO EXTEND THAT EXPAND
THE TERMINATOR.
WHATEVER BUT THAT'LL BE UP TO UP
TO THIS BODY UP TO THE FIGHTER
PILOT IN THE COME BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE WE MAY NOT BE HERE BUT
WE'LL COME BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE FOR REVIEW.
IT'LL COME TO THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATURE AND THEN OF COURSE
THERE WOULD NEED TO BE
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION. TO
POTENTIALLY EXTEND THE PILOT AND
DIED --
REPORT AND DATA WOULD BE PART OF
THE LEGISLATIVE RECORD --
MY NEXT QUESTION FROM A FROM THE
CHAIR.
WHAT HAPPENS IF WE MOVE THIS
TIME FROM --
TWO PM WHICH TWO AM WHICH IS
PRESENTLY AT THE LAW. TO ELEVEN
O'CLOCK.
WILL THAT CHANGE IN THE OUTCOMES
IN YOUR MIND.
I'M SORRY IF THE BUILDER DIED OR
IF IF A COMMUNITY THAT I KNOW OF
WE IF WE'RE TO CHANGE THAT
CHANGES TODAY WELL WILL IT
CHANGE --
ISSUES OR DO YOU ARE EYES OR THE
TALENTS HE'S SOMETHING OF THAT
NATURE THAT DECREASE SO ARE --
AND TO BE CLEAR RIGHT NOW LOCAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE ABILITY TO
STOP ALCOHOL SERVICE BEFORE TWO
AM IN THEIR CLAIM IF COMMUNITIES
WHERE IT STOPS AT TEN ELEVEN AT
NIGHT OR EVEN.
EARLIER SO RIGHT NOW IT'S UP TO
TO A AND AND SO WE DO HAVE --
THEIR COMMUNITIES AROUND THE
STATE WITH EARLIER CLOSING TIMES
I'VE IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW WE WE
I KNOW IT'S IT'S BEEN.
DISMISSED HERE TODAY BUT THE
DATA IS REAL THAT --
AT WHEN YOU COMPARE TIME --
VERSES I DO YOU WHY --
COLLISION RATES UP THERE ZERO
CARL CORRELATION THERE SOME
STATES EITHER GO LEADER THAN
CALIFORNIA.
OR RELATED TO A ON THAT HAVE
SOME OF THE LOWEST IDEA I
CLOSING RATES THERE'S SOME
REALLY CLOSER STATES THAT HAVE
VERY HIGH THERE'S NO CORRELATION
ONE WHERE THE OTHER.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT MAKE SENSE --
IT.
WHETHER YOU WHETHER YOU'RE
CLOSING AT TANNER BEEN NICER TO
AMBER QUORUM THERE IS A CERTAIN
SUBSET OF PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING
TO ACT.
RECKLESSLY UNDERGOING A LEAVE A
BAR DRUNK AND GET INTO THEIR CAR
AND IT DOES NOT MATTER.
WHEN THE SERVICE ENDS THEY'RE
GOING TO GO OUT THERE GOING TO
DRINK AND THEY'RE GONNA DO WHAT
THEY'RE GONNA DO?
ON I WANT TO SAY AND I I
MENTIONED IS THE COMMITTEE WHEN
I PRESENTS BILL LAST YEAR.
THIS IS A VERY PERSONAL ISSUE
FOR ME WHEN I WAS SIX YEARS OLD.
MY AUNT MY FATHER'S ONLY SIBLING
I WAS KILLED BY A DRUNK DRIVER
IN NEW JERSEY IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES WHEN THE DUI LAWS WERE.
HORRIBLE IN TERMS OF HOLDING
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
AYE EXCHANGE OUR FAMILY FOREVER
AND EXTREMELY SENSITIVE AYE TO
THIS ISSUE ARE AND IF I WOULD
NOT BE PROPOSING A BILL. TO
INCREASE DERIVES.
I AND I DO NOT THINK I DON'T
THINK THE DATA SHOWS THAT LATER
CLOSING TIME MEANS MORE.
IDEALIZED IF YOU SCALED
EVERYTHING BACK IN CALIFORNIA
ABOUT.
TWO ELEVEN YOU WOULD STILL HAVE
DO YOU LIES PEOPLE WOULD GO OUT
EARLIER.
I AND YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT A
VERY SENSITIVE ALSO TO THE
HEALTH IMPACTS OF ALCOHOL.
ALCOHOL ABSOLUTELY HAS HEALTH
IMPACTS I AND I THINK IF YOU
LOOK AT PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING THE
LIQUOR STORES.
AND BUYING LIQUOR AND DRINKING
AT HOME OR ELSEWHERE VERSUS
SOMEONE AT AN ELECTRONIC --
DANCE MUSIC MEDIUM PARTY THE
MORNING BY A FIFTEEN DOLLAR
COCKTAIL.
WHICHIS CONTRIBUTING MORE DOOR
HEALTH CRISIS IT'S NOT EVEN THE
SAME UNIVERSE I MEAN THERE'S
BEEN SO MUCH HYPERBOLE.
ABOUT THE THE FIRE AND BRIMSTONE
THAT SUPPOSEDLY GOING TO COME
DOWN ON US IF SEVEN CITIES HAVE
THE OPTION OF SAYING. ONE THIS
THREE OR IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD OR
MAYBE A FEW NIGHTS A YEAR WE'RE
GONNA LET PEOPLE STAY OUT LATER
ON IT'S BEEN SOME OF THE MOST
EXTREME HYPERBOLE I HAVE SEEN.
AROUND ANY BILL --
SO THERE ARE REAL IMPACTS DO YOU
WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT --
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF THE
ALLIES TO ADDRESS THE HEALTH
IMPACTS OF ALCOHOL.
HAVING SOME CLUBS GO A COUPLE
HOURS LATER IS NOT GOING TO BE A
MEANINGFUL PART OF THAT EQUATION
BUT IT WILL ALLOW.
PEOPLE TO ENSURE THEIR
COMMUNITIES MORE WITH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR I THINK YOU'VE
ANSWERED PLEASE MARQUIS VERY
THOROUGHLY I KNOW YOU WORKED
EXTREMELY HARD IN TERMS OF
GETTING.
US TO THIS PARTICULAR POINT --
AND I YOU KNOW.
THIS IS A VOLUNTARY TO THE CITY
COUNCIL IS ALSO HAVE TO ADOPTED
I WAS READING OF THE BILL WHERE --
COMMITTEE IS IS IS IS THERE
TACTICS DOUBTLESS WHERE THERE'S
A HIGH PATROL OFFICER OR SOMEONE
FROM HIGH PATROL DEPARTMENT AS
WELL AS LOCAL P. D..
THAT'S INVOLVED IN TERMS OF
SHAPING UP AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE SO THAT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO ME SO THAT ANSWERS
ALL MY QUESTIONS --
AT THIS POINT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MR LOW AND THE MISTER JONES OR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
OTHER QUESTION --
FOR ARE A PROFESSOR AND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH REPRESENTATIVE IN
OPPOSITION O. WHO ALSO PROVIDED
THE STATISTICS AND DATA.
AND THE QUESTION WAS WHAT WAS
THE LAST TIME THAT YOU WENT OUT
AT A TRICKY AT NIGHT OR A
BEVERAGE AND I TALKED.
APPROXIMATE WHAT TIME WOULD YOU
WHAT WOULD YOU WOULD YOU GO
[inaudible]
PERSONALLY --
HARD TO REMEMBER THE LONG TIME
SINCE I'VE BEEN OUT DRINKING.
BUT I LIVED IN NEW YORK CITY FOR
AWHILE.
AND I DO REMEMBER THE SCREAMING
IN THE FIGHTS IN ALL THE
COMMOTIONON THE CORNERS AT FOUR
AM -- I WAS
ON THE TENTH FLOOR I COULD
REALLY GET TO SLEEP.
UNTIL AFTER A FOUR UNTIL AFTER
FOUR AM.
BECAUSE OF ALL THE FIGHTS AND
SHOUTING GOING ON DOWN STIFF
DOWN ON THE STREETS [inaudible]
YOU'RE.
SO CHECK THE DATA OR THE
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES THAT YOU
HAVE IT'S BEEN QUITE SOMETIME
YOU DON'T RECALL THE LAST TIME
THAT YOU.
MAY HAVE GONE OUT FOR A BEVERAGE
IN SIMILAR AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE ISSUE AREA THAT IS
PERTINENT TO THE POLICY THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW
IT'S IRAQ RIGHT.
WHAT'S PURDUE'S RESEARCH OF THE
CDC AND WHAT THAT SHOWS
CONCLUSIVELY IS THAT THERE IS
HARM KEEPING THE BARS OPEN LATER
[inaudible]
OKAY --
BECAUSE I WOULD OF AT SHARE THAT
IT'S BEEN MY OBSERVATION AND YOU
CAN CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG BUT
INDIVIDUALS THAT DO TYPICALLY GO
OUT YOU SHOULD THEY GO OUT AT
TEN O'CLOCK.
AT IN THESE ESTABLISHMENTS IT
WOULD BE QUITE EMPTY AND AS
MILLENNIAL IT'S BEEN MY
OBSERVATION THAT I'VE SEEN
INDIVIDUALS TYPICALLY GOING OUT
AT ELEVEN THIRTY OR TWELVE
O'CLOCK.
AND WHEN THAT TYPICALLY WHEN
THAT OCCURS LAST CALL MAYBE AT
ONE THIRTY SO WE'RE ONLY TALKING
ABOUT AN HOUR AND A HALF.
TO CONSUME YOUR BEVERAGE OR TWO
OR HOWEVER MANY WE CONSUME.
AND THE CONCERN THAT I WOULD
HAVE AN INTEREST YOUR RESPONSES
THAT WITH SUCH A SMALL SHORT
PERIOD WE KNEW OF TIME.
THAT IT DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO IS ACTUALLY
COUNTER INTUITIVE TO WHAT YOU
WERE SUGGESTING WHICH IS.
TO THIS IF WE WERE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL AND ALLOW FOR AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME
INDIVIDUALS DON'T AS USE MENTION
FEEL LIKE THEY NEED.
TO CHOW DOWN AND CONTINUE TO
FELLOW FIND AN OPERA FAST PACED
RATHER THAN HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO
ABSORB --
THAT THAT ALCOHOL AND OR HOW
THAT HAS APPEARED OF TIME AND OR
OTHER TO COOL DOWN BEFORE THEY
ARE GOING ON TO THE STREETS --
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAD ANY
OTHER CONFLICTING EVIDENCE TO TO
A BEST INDICATE THAT IN FACT IN
ACTUALITY THAT THAT IS NOT THE
CASE IN IN CURRENT REALITY IN
EXISTENCE IF.
YOU'VE EVER EXPERIENCED GOING
OUT CURRENTLY TODAY WELL MY
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE OF THE
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE OF ANYBODY
HERE IS NOT REALLY RELEVANT
WHAT'S RELEVANT IS WHAT THE
RESEARCH IS FROM THE CDC AND THE
CDC.
HAS FOUND THERE IS HARM KEEPING
THE BARS OPEN ANOTHER TWO HOURS
THAT'S THE SCIENCE.
OKAY.
SAME COMMENT.
OKAY MISTER JONES SAWYER.
BUT IT NOW I WANNA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I THINK
THIS IS LONG OVERDUE AND WE'VE
BEEN AT THIS FOR FIFTY YEARS AND
FIFTY YEARS AGO.
OF OUR I DON'T THINK WE EVEN
HAVE SEAT BELTS AND WE GOT TO
LAWS AFFECTED IF YOU'VE GONE. TO
COMPARE.
WHAT ARE LAWS WERE NAY ACTION
RATE FIFTY YEARS AGO COMPARED TO
NOW?
ANNA AND I WILL.
ALLY MYSELF WITH WHICH SOME
ECONOMISTS THAT --
MY COULD YOUNGER COLLEAGUE
MILLENNIAL COLLEAGUES AS I WAS
MILLENNIAL SON.
WHO HAS A?
ON OCCASION HE'S TWENTY SIX ON
OCCASION HE'S CALLED ME.
AND SAID IT IS INDEED RELATED TO
CLOCK IN THE MORNING I'M
FREAKING OUT.
AND HE'D TELL ME I TOOK OVER
DEAD.
SO EVEN OUR PATTERNS BUT HOW WE
DRINK AS A PAIR POST TO BACK IN.
SEVENTY NINE ONE I PROBABLY
GOTTEN EVEN IF I DID I KNOW I
GOT MICHAEL.
AND SO ABSOLUTELY I WAS A
PROBLEM BUT I HAVE A FEELING NOW.
BASED ON WHAT MY COLLEAGUE IS
SAYING THAT YOUNG PEOPLE'S
PATTERNS OF HOW THEY DRINK OF
DRAMATICALLY CHANGE IN ADDITION.
I'VE LOVED.
I'VE BEEN IN OTHER STATES LIKE
FLORIDA --
WERE YOU EVERYBODY THAT CARD AND
HAVE AN OPEN CONTAINER AND AS
LONG AS THE DRIVERS NOT DRINKING.
THAT'S LEGAL I'VE BEEN AND
LOUISIANA WHERE YOU PULL UP WE
GET UP MARGARITA LIKE IT.
LIKELY DRIVE TO LOOK AT TACO
BELL AND SO I'VE SEEN SOME
REALLY ABHORRENT WAYS OF DOING
THIS I DON'T SEE THAT.
IN YOUR BILL ESPECIALLY STATE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT GATHERING
DATA THAT WAS GOING TO BE MY
QUESTION I'M FLAT.
ON MY COLLEAGUE FROM CARSON --
ASKED ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I THINK
LA AND THE OTHER CITIES WILL BE
PERFECT EXAMPLES OF HOW WE CAN
ACTUALLY LOOK AT THIS AND SEE --
WHAT WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE ON
HOW WE CAN IMPROVE IT?
THE OTHER THING IS ALSO BEING
FROM LOS ANGELES ON LOCAL
CONTROL -- I
BELIEVED AT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS A LOCAL COUNCIL
PEOPLE WILL COME UP WITH A WILL
DEVELOP A PLAN.
WORKING WITH CH P. AND OTHERS SO
THAT WILL BE THE SAFEST.
POSSIBLE SITUATION GROW FROM TWO
O'CLOCK TO FOUR O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING AND AND THAT GIVES ME ON
A LOT OF SENSE OF SECURITY.
THAT THEY'RE NOT JUST GOING TO
OPEN THE FLOODGATES FROM AIR
GOING TO BE VERY VERY ON ON
DELIBERATE.
AND HOW IN YOUR THINKING AND HOW
THEY ACTUALLY OPEN UP AND ALLOW
THESE ESTABLISHMENTS OF TO STAY
OPEN.
AND SO UPBEAT YOU'VE KIND OF
ANSWERED --
MY QUESTIONS AND I'LL JUST LEAVE
YOU WITH THIS I EVERY MONDAY
SINCE I'VE BEEN ELECTED --
I TAKE THE FIRST FLIGHT OUT OF
LA.
SOMETIME JUST FIVE TEN IN THE
MORNING SOMETIME TO SIX IN THE
MORNING.
I'M ON WROTE.
IT AT FOUR FIVE O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING [inaudible]
ALMOST DESERTED.
AND I DON'T SEE.
ANY PROBLEMS THAT THAT MAYBE.
OTHER PEOPLE OR ALLUDING TO
BECAUSE I CAN'T SEE THAT MANY
PEOPLE OUT THERE EVEN NOW.
AND SO OF IT WILL BE GREAT TO
SEE [inaudible]
FURTHER.
WHAT YOU DEBT WHICH YOU GET
AFTER FIVE YEARS OF A?
STUDY WHETHER OR NOT THAT
CHANGES BECAUSE I ACTUALLY PLAN
TO BE HERE FOR THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS SO TO
THANK YOU.
COULD WE HAVE ADDITIONAL.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS.
GOD LIKE.
TO FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU.
CENTER FOR YOUR GIL JENSEN WORK
ON THIS ISSUE WE'VE WORKED
TOGETHER SEVERAL YEARS A ON THIS
SUBJECT --
YOUR COLLABORATION WITH THIS
COMMITTEE I THINK LAST YEAR WE
TOOK EIGHTEEN TWENTY AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL --
WE CERTAINLY GOT INTO THE WEEDS
AND MADE SOME IMPORT REFINEMENTS.
AND THEN I WOULD.
ARGUE WE CONTINUE TO FIND THE
BILL THIS YEAR OF WOULD REPORT
BACK LIMITING THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL WITH SELECT A BURST OF
CITIES THAT.
I HAVE LOCAL SUPPORT FOR SOME.
LOCAL CONTROL ON THE SUBJECT OF
WHETHER IT BE AS YOU SAID FOR A
DISTRICT A FEW NIGHTS A YEAR OR
SOMETHING LARGER.
ARMED AND THAT THAT REPORT WOULD
THEN COME BACK. TO THE
LEGISLATURE OUGHT TO BE REVIEWED
AND WE MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
ADDING AMENDMENT --
TO ENSURE THAT BOTH A POLICY
COMMITTEES IN BOTH HOUSES OF OUR
RECEIPT OF THAT INFORMATION TO
THOSE REPORTS OF THAT WE CAN
FURTHER --
REFINE THIS ISSUE LIKE RICHARD
JONES SAWYER FIVE YEARS.
AND ASKING YOU THESE QUESTIONS.
TO THAT WITNESSES I APPRECIATE
THE CONCERNS RAISED --
I THINK.
A LOT MANY OF THOSE CONCERNS ARE
CERTAINLY THE SPIRIT BEHIND
THOSE CONCERNS ARE AT THE CORE
OF THE AMENDMENTS WE'VE MADE SO
THAT WERE PROPERLY ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE AND TAKING SERIOUSLY --
ANY ISSUES THAT COULD DEVELOP
AND MONITOR IN THOSE ISSUES IN
ADDRESSING THAT IF NECESSARY
[inaudible]
I'M.
FAMILIAR WITH THE DATA THAT
SENATORS SHARED WITH THE
COMMITTEE --
CERTAINLY SEEMS TO SUGGEST OR SO.
AT BARE MINIMUM A LACK OF
CONSISTENCY OR PATTERN.
I KNOW WE'VE CITED A LOT OF
OTHER STUDIES --
NO COMMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE I
KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT DRUNK
DRIVING IN THE ON THE
INCREMENTAL OR OR OR OR SPIKE IN
A RECENT STATISTICS THERE.
IT BE GREAT IF YOU COULD SUBMIT
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR OUR REVIEW
IN OUR RECORDS --
DOES STATISTICS OVER THE LAST
TEN TO FIFTEEN YEARS --
AND ANY RELATION A BETWEEN
COMMITTEE ARE COMMUNITIES RATHER
THE HAVE EARLIER HOURS VERSUS
LATE AND SO THAT WE CAN AT A
FURTHER ESTABLISH STATEN --
I'LL CALL JUSTICE PROVIDED A
REPORT TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR REVIEW.
THERE WAS SOME REFERENCE AND ALL
DIRECTORS QUESTION TO THE
GENTLEMAN FROM ALCOHOL JUSTICE
ABOUT INTERNATIONAL --
CIRCUMSTANCES --
AND I THINK YOU REFERENCED
AMSTERDAM AND IN HERE IF YOU
REFERENCE ANY OTHER SPECIFIC
COUNTRIES.
I DON'T SEE THAT IN THIS
PARTICULAR PROVIDE A REPORT THAT
YOU PROVIDED A BUT IF YOU WANT.
TO PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE WITH
FURTHER INFORMATION ON THIS
SUBJECT I THINK THAT WILL BE
HELPFUL IN UNDERSTANDING.
THE OUTCOMES --
AND ANY CHANGES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED AS A RESULT OF THOSE
OUTCOMES IN POLICY THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD ON THE SUBJECT SO FEW
BE KIND ENOUGH TO PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION --
FOR FURTHER REVIEW.
AND SENATOR APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUED A EFFORT TO REFINE THE
BILL WOULD.
TAKING THE COMMITTEE MEMBER IT'S
TODAY -- AND
WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
MISTER JONES SAWYER SECOND FROM
MR LOW.
AND WE HAVE A DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS --
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AT MY CLOTHES.
SERVICE CENTER.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER WE JUST
BRIEFLY POT RESULT THANK YOU FOR
ALL THE COMMENTS AND AND
QUESTIONS ONE THING I JUST
WANTED I KNOW I THINK GOT
SOMETIMES.
OUT WHEN IT COMES TO NIGHT LIFE.
ARE.
IT'S TEMPTING TAKE A VERY AYE
NARROW VIEW OF WHAT IT IS --
WE'VE HEARD HERE TODAY ZOMBIE
OPPONENTS --
WHAT I THINK WAS CALLED SPECIAL
INTERESTS ARE WHICH IS I THINK
WHAT THEY'RE REFERRING TO IS THE
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT EMPLOY A
LOT OF PEOPLE AND THAT?
GOD FOR BID MAKE MONEY FROM OF
BEING OPEN AS A AS A BUSINESS --
WE WE COURSE FOCUS LEGITIMATELY
ON PUBLIC HEALTH THE PUBLIC
SAFETY WHICH IS BILL DIES.
I'VE TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
GOOD PLANNING AROUND SAFETY IN
PARTICULAR --
AND OF COURSE THAT IS ALWAYS AN
ASPECT OF MY LIFE WE NEED TO BE
ON THE LOOK OUT.
FOR BUT NAY LATE IS NOT JUST
ABOUT BUSINESS IS MAKING MONEY
AND BAD THINGS HAPPENING IN
TERMS OF SAFETY OR HEALTH.
NAY LIKE DOESN'T EXIST UNLESS
YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO GO
OUT.
AND BE WITH THEIR COMMUNITY AND
AND CELEBRATE.
AND HAVE A GOOD TIME DOT DOT
WHAT IT'S ABOUT WHEN I THINK
ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE KNOW MR LOW
PROBABLY SECOND THIS IS IT.
MY BACK WHEN I WAS A LOT YOUNGER
OTHER AND TODAY IS A YOUNG GAY
MAN.
GOOD NIGHT LIFE WAS WHERE I
FOUND MY COMMUNITY AND THE LGBT
COMMUNITY IS NOT THE ONLY
COMMUNITY --
WHERE OUR NIGHTLIFE VENUES HAVE
PLAYED AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN OUR
CULTURE WE LOOK AT THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY?
HISTORICALLY AS WELL THESE ARE
PLACES WHERE WE GO.
AND ESTABLISH A CREATE --
AND FIND COMMUNITY.
I AND YOU KNOW RECENTLY A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO I WAS IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD SUPERMARKET TUNE
FOOD SHOPPING --
AND I WAS CHECKING OUT AND THEIR
CASHIER WAS A YOUNG MAN.
WHO SAID TO ME?
HE SAID HEY I'M I WANNA THANK
YOU FOR DOING THAT AND I LIKE
BILL.
I GET OFF WORK AT MIDNIGHT.
AND BY THE TIME I GET HOME AND
CHANGE AND GO TO THE BAR IT'S
ABOUT ONE FIFTEEN AND I USUALLY
HAVE ABOUT A HALF AN HOUR.
I TO GO OUT HE SAID SO THANK YOU
FOR UNDERSTANDING THAT PEOPLE
LIKE ME EXIST.
NOT EVERYONE WORKS A NINE TO
FIVE JOB.
NOT EVERYONE GOES TO BED AS
EARLY AS I GO TO BED --
THESE DAYS SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO
STEP OUT OF OUR OWN EXPERIENCES
AND RECOGNIZE THAT DIFFERENT
PEOPLE.
EXPERIENCE THE WORLD DIFFERENTLY.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS IS ABOUT
LETTING PEOPLE HAVE THEIR FUN
AND DO THEIR THING IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
OKAY MEMBERS THIS IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CRANK AYE
GRAY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO ACOSTA.
ACOSTA NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I BERMAN.
BERMAN I BONTA.
BONTA AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY NO COOPER.
COOPER NOT VOTING.
DAILY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
GALLAGHER NO [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO LEVINE.
LEVINE NO LOW.
LOW AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SALAS [inaudible]
WALDRON.
THEY SAID THAT BILL NEEDS ONE
MORE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU ALEX.
OKAY AT THIS TIME MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE FINAL ITEM.
ON THE AGENDA [inaudible]
AND ASK [inaudible]
SENATOR MCGUIRE. TO JOIN US.
UP FRONT PRESENT --
HIS ITEM THIS IS ITEM FOUR SP
[inaudible]
EIGHT THREE THREE WELCOME
SENATOR.
THAT CENTER YOU HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH --
MEMBERS I KNOW THAT I MEAN IF
YOU HAVE TO CATCH FLIGHTS I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH IT --
FOR BOTH REPUBLICAN DEMOCRATIC
SUPPORT IN THE COMMITTEE.
ALL SAY --
TWENTY SECONDS MISTER CHAIR
NIGHT OF OCTOBER EIGHTEENTH
LIVES OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS FOREVER.
THIS CREATES A STATEWIDE
STANDARD FOR EMERGENCY ALERTS WE
HAVE -- TO
WELL RESPECTED FIRE CHIEFS ALONG
WITH AT THE STUDENTS WHO LOST
HER MOTHER IN A FIRE BECAUSE SHE
DID NOT RECEIVE AN ALERT.
UP BUT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I DON'T THINK.
IT WILL KEEP A VERY VERY BRIEF
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
MARQUARDT AGGRESSIVE THING THAT
FIRE CHIEF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
HELP CHIEFS AS WELL AS FAR
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATE CALIFORNIA A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF CENTER
REQUIRES BILL.
IT DAN GEORGE LE BAR CHIEF
GOLDBERG SO FAR PROTECTION
DISTRICT UP IN CINEMA COUNTY.
WENT THROUGH THE OCTOBER --
FIRE THINGS AND WE DO SUPPORT A
STATEWIDE EMERGENCY ALERT SYSTEM --
WITH OVER FOUR MILLION TOURISTS
COMING HAVING SOMETHING
STATEWIDE SO THAT THEY GET
NOTIFIED.
WOULD BE A GREAT BENEFIT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
UNDER GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
VERS MY NAME IS JESSICA CHáVEZ
ON A RESIDENT SANTA ROSA AND WE
JUST REALLY NEED A STATEWIDE.
SENATE FROM MURDERS HILLARD'S I
RECEIVED.
MY MOTHER CALLED ME FROM HER
BURNING HOUSE THAT NIGHT AND SHE
WAS TRAPPED AND SHE OUT JUST
WANT TO SLEEP THAT'S WHAT YOU
DON'T WANT TO SLEEP.
DID YOU CHARTER FOR OFF I HAVE
NO IDEA BUT SHE DID NOT KNOW
THAT THAT REFERRAL WAS COMING
TOWARDS HER HOUSE.
AND WE DESPERATELY NEED THAT THE
STANDARD.
THAT THOSE WTA ALERTS GO OUT
THEY WAKE YOU UP THEY THEY FORCE
YOU TO TURN YOUR PHONE OFF.
BEFORE THEY START MAKING THAT
ANNOYING SOUND THEY WAKE YOU OF
THOSE OF YOU KNOW DISASTER
COMING FROM YOUR IN YOUR WAY YOU
DON'T KNOW.
SO I JUST --
UNIX ALL THOSE WONDERFUL IF
YOU'RE AWAKE AND WATCHING YOUR
TEXT MESSAGES BUT I CAN'T TELL
YOU HOW MANY TEXT WHICH IS I'VE
SLEPT THROUGH.
IS NOT GOOD ENOUGH TO WAKE
PEOPLE UP A LITTLE BIT.
OF A DISASTER THE COMES WHEN
EVERYONE'S ASLEEP.
SO -- IT'S
CLEAR WE NEED AN OPT UNIVERSAL
OPT OUT SYSTEM FOR EMERGENCY
ALERTS.
OR TO REACH EVERYONE IN THE AREA
INCLUDING ALL OF OUR VISITORS
WOULD NOT EVEN THINK THE SENATE
FROM EXCEL FOR EVERY ZIP CODE.
THE FACT THAT'S NOT A COUNTIES
EMERGES SERVICES MOTHER DECIDED
A YEAR IN ADVANCE NOT TO USE THE
OUIJA.
ALERTNESS OBSERVES INFURIATING
THE DECISION WAS BASED ON THEIR
OWNERS BELIEVE THAT WE MUST NOT
BE FOCAL LIVES AND AND WE THEY
CAN BE FOCUS THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA DESERVE BETTER WE
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY WE MUST HAVE
THE WILL AND MEANS TO USE IT.
WE WAS PASSES BOOKER TO
STATEWIDE EMERGENCY STANDARD
PLEASE WHAT YES HONESTY.
EIGHT THIRTY THREE IT MIGHT SAVE
SOMEONE YOU LOVE THANK YOU.
THEY FREE TEST WILL.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
YEAH SO MANY OF MICHAEL
COCKERELL I AM A REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY SERVICE
ASSOCIATION ON THIS SEE SO.
PERSONALLY I JUST RETIRED AS THE
DIRECTOR OF SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES AFTER
THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
AND I PERSONALLY HAVE PUSH THAT
SEND BUTTON TO SEND OUT BIRDS
AND NOTICES FOR ANYWHERE FROM
FLOOD EVACUATIONS NINE ONE ONE
OUTAGES IN AMBER ALERTS.
WE JUST DID SEND AN ELECTRONIC
COPY OF OUR COMMENTS --
TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS CEASAR
IS COMPRISED OF LOCAL EMERGENCY
MANAGERS FROM LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WHETHER THAT BE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS CITIES
COUNTIES.
THERE'S ALSO SOME STATE
EMPLOYEES ARE INVOLVED.
PIPER NONPROFITS AND KNOW THE
PRIVATE BUSINESS SECTOR.
MAJORITY OF THE LARGE AND
WARNINGS OF WERE TALKING ABOUT
HERE ARE ACTUALLY.
BEING SENT BY OUR MEMBERS.
CAESAR THOUGH HAS.
THREE PRIMARY POINTS WE WANT --
TO PRESENT TO YOU ONE IS WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S REMOVAL
OF THE ITEM OF A RED ALERTS
SINCE THAT IS A PROPRIETORY
SOFTWARE WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT.
HOWEVER WERE ALSO A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED THAT THERE'S A A LACK
OF DISCUSSION ON COST OF THIS OF
WHICH COULD BE A BECOME A LOCAL
MANDATE.
CAESAR HAS CHANGED ITS STATUS TO
SUPPORT IF AMENDED AND AMENDED
CONCERNED IS AGAIN THE ONGOING
OF RESIN REVENUE.
STREAM FOR THE SUPPORTING OF IT.
ONE OF OUR MEMBERS HAD WRECKED
THEY HAD MENTIONED BASED ON HIS
CALCULATIONS IS THAT WOULD COST
ABOUT A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
TO ESTABLISH.
A FULLY FUNCTIONAL ALERT MORNING
SYSTEM THERE ARE SYSTEMS OUT
THERE ARE LOWER SUMMER HIRE.
THAT DOES INCLUDE THE ONGOING
ANNUAL COSTS IN REPLACEMENTS
COSTS.
WHEN OUR ISSUE THAT WE'RE LUBICK
CONCERNED ABOUT IS IT'S ONLY
BEEN A COUPLE DAYS SINCE WE
RECEIVED THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY SERVICES?
A LETTER CONCERNING --
ARE POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS.
AND IN OUT THERE IS A COUPLE
ITEMS WERE WERE WERE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT.
JURISDICTION SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
PASS INDIVIDUAL --
RESOLUTIONS WITH THE GOVERNING
BOARDS IF THEY DO.
DETRACT FROM THE PROPOSED CAL
YES OF MEN DID.
NOT CHANGES.
AND IT THAT BECOMES I'VE ONES LA
SIZE FITS ALL SITUATIONS WE FEEL
THERE SHOULD BE SOME FLEXIBILITY.
THERE'S ALSO A BABY UP PROPOSAL
TO DEVELOP A YOU HAVE A MOTION
THE SECOND SIR IF YOU WANT TO
WRAP UP AND SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS
TO COMMITTEE OF FROM BANKERS
THAT BECAUSE OKAY THANK YOU
VIDAK ME MEMBERS AND THE AUTHORS
OFFICE.
I ADDITIONAL GOT TESTIMONY IN
THE BACK.
CHRIS FORSYTH REPRESENTING OPTI
STREAMS AT CLOVIS CALIFORNIA
COMPANY THAT MANUFACTURES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE INDEPENDENT
MOBILE OPERATING SATELLITE
EMERGENCY SYSTEM.
WE APPRECIATE THE UP POLICY
DISCUSSION REFLECTED IN YOUR
ANALYSIS REGARDING ENSURING
CALIFORNIA.
HAS BACKUP TECHNOLOGY FOR WHEN
OUR EMERGENCY COMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE NEBULAE BREAKS
DOWN AS IT DID IN CINEMA.
AND THAT TECHNOLOGY EXISTS TODAY
ITS MENU CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
CHRIS CONRAD BUZZING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND SUPPORT.
DAVID JONES ABOUT THE CITIES OF
SANTA ROSA THE CITIES OF IRAN
AND CITY OF GLENDALE SPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS DEREK
DOLPHY UNHAPPILY CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS.
MICHAEL DAFT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
IMMENSE ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA AND MO WHICH I ORDER
ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE COUNTIES OF
DOUBT THAT MEDICINE NO AND
CINNAMON SPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BURSTING
SHIPOWNER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
WHEN OF A SUPPORTIVE AMENDED
POSITION ON THIS BILL BUT WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITMENT
FROM THE AUTHOR. FOR WORKING OUT
OR ISSUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST
DOUG SUPERS IN BE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT.
AFFECT WORRY FOR THE SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FIREFIGHTERS
ASSOCIATION.
JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION THAT WE WANT TO TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY THINK THE CHAIRS
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE AUTHOR
FOR HEARING OUR CONCERNS AND
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
CLEARLY ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION.
SE NON WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR I I SHOULD YOU BE TAKING
AMENDMENT --
I WILL SERENADE JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH AT MISTER
CHAIR THAT FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK
ON THIS BILL YOUR WONDERFUL
STAFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT
WILL BE ACCEPTING THEM IT ALSO I
THINK IN THIS AGUIAR-CURRY.
MISSES THE BEING WHO ARE
PRINCIPLE CO AUTHORS IN THIS
BILL AND HAVE GONE THROUGH THIS
WITH US IN VERY VERY GRATEFUL
FOR POKER SUPPORT.
THEY CAN THANK YOU SIR YOU HAVE
A MOTION A SECOND. TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS --
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
GRAY AYE GRAY AYE BIGELOW AYE
BIGELOW AYE ACOSTA.
I WEAR PERRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BERMAN BERMAN
AYE BONTA BONTA AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER IDEALLY [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I EDUARDO GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GIPSON OR
GIPSON AYE GLORIA [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY AYE LACKEY LACKEY AYE
LEVINE.
LEVINE EYES.
LOW [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SELES.
RUBIO AYE SALAS AYE [inaudible]
WALDRON.
THAT THOSE OUTSIDER.
OKAY MEMBERS WE HAVE A BILL LONG
CALL -- THIS
IS ITEM. FIVE S. B. NINE OH FIVE
SEARCHES PLEASE LIFT THE CALL.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
DALY.
EDUARDO GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA I
SO THIS [inaudible]
WALDRON.
THAT BILLS OUT.
OKAY MEMBERS WILL LEAVE THE
WE'LL TAKE OUT ON THIS FOR THE
NEXT -- TWO
AND A HALF MINUTES
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
SHE PLEASE DON'T CENTERS WOULD
HELP [inaudible] ONE DAY.
LONG ROAD OUT HERE BUT I DID NOT
[inaudible]
MOMENT
YEAH.
YOU GUYS ARE.
SO SHOULD I THEREAFTER
[inaudible]
EARLIER [inaudible]
YEAH ME [inaudible]
I WOULD.
WE NEED TO USE THAT.
JOINT HEARING THERE [inaudible]
THANKS